welcome to rochford district council's
remote council meeting
of the 14th of july 2020
and a warm welcome to anybody watching
this via the live stream
i shall now take item one on the agenda
apologies for
absence we have received apologies from
councillor mrs diane hoy
and i believe there's no one else thank
you
item two uh minutes of the annual
meeting held on the 9th of july
2020 members are you happy for me to
sign in due course the minutes of the
annual council meeting held on the 9th
of july
i will assume agreement unless anyone
clicks on the raise
hand icon
welcome to zoom into your meeting
followed by hash
councilor michael hoy
thank you i'm playing around with the
movie there um yes thank you chairman
i've just got a
concern around the second paragraph on
the second page of the minutes
participant id followed by hash sorry
that noise i think emotionally speaking
can you go on
this confuse me a bit um on the
minutes i'm just getting up again of the
9th of july
second paragraph on page two three
um what term counselor steptoe said
i do believe for fullness and
completeness
that it should include the statement he
made regarding
bullying intimidation and control this
is in the public domain it is on the
front page of yesterday's echo
i think it looks like we as a councillor
trying to cover it up if we do not
include this
i know it may be uncomfortable um but i
think it
just should be included i'll come back
to your
counselor thank you
sorry chairman your lips are moving but
no sound is coming out
sorry council high my apologies also
chairman councillor my uh burton has
lost audio as well
okay bear with us for that let me answer
this question first
um the minutes are purely a summary
of the annual council and do not go into
a great detail with regards to matters
said it's purely a brief summary of the
matters discussed okay
counts to mrs mason
counselor mrs mason thank you mr
chairman i'm afraid
my internet isn't brilliant so you'll
have to bear with me if it appears a
little slow
rather than being patient um i
echo what's her counselor mr hawaii has
said
a brief summary yes but you haven't put
a brief summary in there
there's a comprehensive report
on um the annual council there's there's
a whole page
and yet something very significant that
has been missed out and i don't think
that editing
the um minutes
is correct in this way and i would
second
councillor hoy's request that
they are that the remarks made
are recorded secondly as a matter of
fact
the minutes are incorrect the apologies
for absence were received from
counsellor and then it says start typing
text
there were apologies they were given and
they've not been recorded uh councillor
tony mrs castle was one council of mrs
hoyer is another
and i'm sure the other members will be
able to
enlighten you about the other members
that
you've missed out of the minutes but in
the meantime
as i say councillor and myself have
requested
formally that the minutes include the
comments made by a councillor steptoe
thank you thank you uh
scare counselor mrs mason um i'll repeat
what i've said
to councillor hoy and i would emphasize
that the speeches
of uh councillors wooten and steptoe
are summaries of thanks for their past
year with regards to the apologies
they will be amended so thank you for
your comments
chairman point of order um councillor
chris stanley
has not been allowed in to the meeting
yet please
he will be he has but he's just slow
getting in there
he has been allowed in council newport
members then i um i see no other hand
icons
uh sorry chairman uh counselor newport
has
he's already spoken
to newport do you wish to speak again
no chairman sorry i've put my hand down
members did i ask you to mute your
microphones please when not speaking
thank you
remember somebody has joined by
telephone we're not sure who that is
could they please declare themselves
council burdens you
just counseled me thank you
you're muted german
members apart from the amendments that
i've identified
i will sign in due course the minutes of
the annual
council meeting held on the 9th
i'm on a point of order chairman don't
we vote on this
um i've already explained
muted again german okay i can see your
mouth moving but no words are coming out
yeah we need to check whether or not
um
council ahoy did you move in motion
could you if you did could repeat it
please
hear a word you were saying chairman
sorry i think the sound is very bad
tonight for some reason
all round um yes i i am
moved to motion to to change the second
paragraph to include the word
in more fully
that counselor steptoe also
indicated that there's bullying
intimidation and control
okay and for completeness this should be
included otherwise
we would be we could being
accused of covering up these allegations
do you have a second uh
do you have a second uh yes i think
councilman mrs mason was seconding that
council is mason did you second that yes
i did
mr chairman thank you
members you've all heard the motion
that's put forward by council high
seconded by councillor mrs mason
i shall ask for a vote of either the
roll call if you can indicate whether
you're
you wish to have a recorded vote or
you're for against
or abstain
i shall continue with the roll call
members councillor
mrs belton
against do you wish to have a recorded
vote
apologies no recorded vote councillor
burton
councillor burton councillor burton can
you hear me
he can't hear me ask him does he want to
record it
do you want a recorded vote and are you
for the motion no recorded votes
and are you for the motion
okay thanks to those councillor canel
uh no recorded votes but for the motion
thank you councillor mr carter
yeah no recorded vote against the motion
thank you councillor mrs carter
yes thank you chairman uh recorded vote
please and
uh four thank you myself councillor
drake no recorded vote
and against the motion counselor fd
no recording votes and against the
motion thank you chairman councillor
eves
recorded vote and for the motion
councillor gooding
no recorded vote and against the motion
chair thank you
thank you council hazelwood
councillor hookway
for a recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor mr hoyne for
a recorded vote and for the motion thank
you chairman
councillor hudson i don't require a
recorded vote
i'm against emotion councillor
no and against thank you councillor mrs
mason
thank you mr chairman for the recorded
vote
and for the motion for transparency
thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson no for the
recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman thank you councillor
merrick
no and against thank you councillor
milne
no and against council newport
for a recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor mrs pavlin
uh no and against councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and against thank
you councillor mrs shaw
no record your vote and against
promotion councillor mr shaw
no recorded vote against the motion
council smith
no recorded vote against council sparing
no recorded vote against council steptoe
a recorded vote
could you repeat that please
no recorded vote and four
thank you council stanley
for both please thank you
can you repeat that please
counselor stanley for both please
thank you councillor ward
no sorry no
and against thank you council webb
no and against councillor mrs weston
no recorded though and abstain from
chairman
councillor wilkinson uh yes and for the
motion please
councillor williams thank you chairman
no and for no sorry no and against
council wilson yes for recorded vote
and for the motion thank you members
councillor woodson no and against
councillor mrs butcher i missed you out
my apologies
yes thank you chairman uh no recorded
vote
and abstain from the motion thank you
i'll come back to you members
okay
that's right because we haven't got
hazel
no christina
[Music]
excuse me mr chairman i'm not sure if
there's something wrong with my sound i
can't hear anything
sounds perfect can hear you perfectly
i do apologize we will have to
take that vote again for technical
reasons
i will go through the names uh once
again
a little bit more slowly this time so if
again if you can indicate whether you
would like a recorded vote
for or against or which to abstain
chairman why are you doing that uh uh
councillor canal's got his hand i've
taken his hand up a while now i'm not
sure he wants a
word on this one thank you councillor
canel
do you wish to speak i was actually
regarding the
um apologies for absence so i was
waiting till
after the vote i didn't realize we'd
need to revoke apologies
whilst i'm speaking it was essentially i
i wasn't
aware of uh i've forgotten already
councillor mrs mason's list of absentees
uh it was just to ensure that i was um
noted on on that as an apology for
absence last meeting thank you chairman
perspective of the minute yes
yes yes okay yes right so that will be
noted counselor
all right here we go again members
counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote against the motion
councilor burton
chairman councillor burton's having
great difficulty he keeps getting frozen
he he can hear the
meeting on his phone but he's having
problems speaking
if we can see you counselor burton if
you can
thumbs up or thumbs down he's on the
phone he's on the phone
can you unmute and can you see can you
unmute yourself councillor burton please
council belton revolted no and again
can you hear me now chairman yes yes yep
right sorry i apologize i can't i'm
having great difficulties here
um against a recorded vote
and against the motion thank you
councillor mrs butcher
yes thank you no recorded vote and
abstain from the motion
councilor mr cannell
recorded vote not required but for the
motion
council mr carter
no recorded vote and against
councillor mrs carter thank
chair um a recorded vote please and four
myself against the accorded uh recorded
vote and against the motion
councillor efti ainston against
thank you councillor eves for recorded
votes and
for the motion thank you chair
councillor mrs goodin
against the recorded vote and against
the motion
thank you chair councillor hawkway
uh for the a recorded vote
and for the motion thank you councillor
mr hoy
for the recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
council councillor mr hudson
against the recorded vote against the
motion thank you councillor ionu
for the recorded vote and force for the
motion
thank you councillor mr lucas gill
no end against councillor mrs lumley
no and against councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman for a recorded
vote
and for the motion councillor mrs
macpherson
against the recorded vote and for the
motion thank you chairman
thank you councillor mr merrick
no and against
uh no and against thank you
council mrs rowe thank you chairman no
and against councillor mrs shaw
no against thank you councillor mr shaw
and against weights
i need to get these numbers
and
[Music]
no recorded vote and against council
sparing
no recorded voting against council
stanley
four and four please counsel steptoe
recorded vote and for the motion
council award no and against chairman
thank you council webb no and against
chairman councillor
apologies for the delay chairman uh four
recorded voting for the motion please
council wilson all the recorders though
and for the motion thank you councillor
woodson no recorded vote
german and against
members there will be a recorded vote
there were 13 members for the motion
21 against and one
abstention so the um
the motion has been lost thank you
members
chaired on a point of order i think
there was two abstentions
yeah yes both of us both times
yeah i can concur with that actually put
another point of order
uh unless my arithmetic is incorrect 13
plus 21. was it
was it 24. it was the figures
can you repeat the figures mr chairman
because they seem to
not add up we're working on it counselor
mrs mason will be come back come on
thank you
members clarification is still a
recorded vote there were 13 votes for
the motion 21 against and two
abstentions
her apologies so again that motion has
been lost
um and i will members sign the minutes
of the meeting on the 9th of july as
soon as practical
i shall now take item 3 on the agenda
members declarations of interest are
there any
declaration of interest because i'm the
chairman of
the rochford chamber of trade that
affects the cctv working group from
number 13. thank you councillor ionu any
others
chairman i think as i was on the group
at
raley town council which is temporarily
suspended pending the outcome of the
cctv decisions at rockford
perhaps i should declare an interest
thank you counselor
council newport yes chairman i would
like to declare an interest in item
13 by way of being a member of
rayleigh town council and being on the
community safety group
which was discussing the cctv
thank you
council alum lee
yes chairman as a chairman of rayleigh
town council currently but also as a
member of the
community safety working group which was
considering
um possibility of cctv
but the report will go to council for
further consideration thank you council
lumley any
others yes council ward
thank you chairman uh the same as the
previous
member of raineytown council and also on
the working group that discussed cctv
for rowdy town council any others
no
members i shall now take item four on
the agenda announcements from the
chairman leader or
head of paid service members
there are none
i'd agenda item five public questions
and member questions on notice
members there are none
agenda item six business from last
meeting
members does any anyone have any
questions relating to the business from
the council
meet minutes held on the 18th of
february 2020 or the 19th of may 2020
silence implies ascent council mrs
can you hear okay now me chairman
um thank you mr chairman these are
queries relating or matters arising
from the minutes of the 18th of february
just for clarity
um on page 22
um it has been um
i'm just trying to read it the uh
council's monitoring officers
would include this issue with her annual
monitoring officer report to members
this would be done in april now
i have since that we've had some
communications with the managing
director who's advised us that
council working has been carried out as
normal which i think is
absolutely fantastic bearing in mind the
difficult situations
everyone has had to
deal with and the changes of practice
i requested a copy of this report from
the officers
on the 2nd of july i've not had a
response
so i wonder if this report has been
produced
and if so if it can be circulated and if
it hasn't been produced
when it will be produced
thank you mr chairman
council mrs mason the report
unfortunately has not been issued as yet
due to
illness of the monitoring officer and it
will be issued
just as soon as possible thank you
there's no time span for that then
because we're what july now
three months later would it be within a
month perhaps
would that be reasonable
mrs mason you'll be updated outside of
this meeting if that's okay
thank you yes that's fine thank you mr
chairman appreciated
counsellor uh councillor canel
uh thank you chair uh in a similar vein
um the
the meeting i believe we're talking
about the meeting that took place five
months ago in february
um i was just wondering uh the best way
to get an update on the eu emotion that
was passed
on that date thank you chair
the strategic director to update outside
the meeting
chairman you're muted still
counselor canal uh once again we'll give
you an update on that outside of this
meeting
thank you thank you
um chairman could you make sure those go
to all members please
yes um let me finish if you may
um i will assume um uh that you're in
agreement
unless you click on the raised hand
icon
there's been no indication members i
should take that as agreed thank you
very much
and they will be allocated they will be
sent to all members
members i will take item eight on the
agenda to consider any reports from the
executive and committees to council
item eight one report of the review
committee treasury management annual
review
2019 and 2020
councillor burton will introduce the
report
council burton hello chairman can you
hear me
yes we can hear your counselor person
okay thank you apologies again um
as members will have seen this is the
um the third report relating to the
2019-2020 municipal year
and this is an an and a new so it's
carl's passing an annual review of the
council's treasury management activities
for that period
um this report is fairly short and
concise
um it's presented to the review
committee at our last meeting where it
was agreed it would be presented
for council with a recommendation to
approve
um naomi locust is available this
evening
um to answer an additional question that
members may have however if there aren't
any
um i recommend moving this report for
approval thank you
thank you councilor burton members are
there any questions
counsellor mr hoy
thank you chairman sorry there's no
question i just want to make a very
short statement on this
this is regarding how i'll be voting
tonight which is to abstain
this is not because i think the work
that's been done is poor
it's not because i think it's wrong i
think a good job has been done and some
of them are very good indeed
however overall i i feel that it just
does not go far enough for me from my
perspective and my standing i think it
should have been
had more teeth and should have had more
targets
and certainly had political oversight
either through the um
portfolio holder for the environment or
the um leader or deputy leader of the
council that is all i'll be abstaining i
will not be voting against this
i think it's a step forward but in my
view it's a smaller step than i think it
could have been
thank you councillor anybody else wish
to speak
no then members
council williams thank you chairman just
for clarity um council ahoy mentioned
uh this should have been uh overview by
the um
portfolio of the environment
please continue well point folder
chairman council macpherson point of
order
i think counselor michael hoy is
speaking on the wrong paper
i've just said that councilman my sound
is awful at the moment
and i thought it was something else we
were speaking about i'm a terrible
knight
no i think we've got your view on the
next paper
yes but does that uh change your point
of view then council lahore
my point of view has never changed on
this this report is fine thank you very
much
members there is one recommendation at
paragraph 2.1 of the report
that the contents of the treasury
management annual review be noted
and again i assume that unless anybody
clicks on the raise hand icon
that that is noted members
has been noted thank you very much
i shall now go on to item 8
2 report of the review committee carbon
neutral by 2030
and again councillor burton will
introduce
this report councillor burton
thank you chairman can you just confirm
you can hear me again
i can hear your counselor person okay
thank you
okay um 8.2 um firstly i'd like to again
thank members of the carbon neutral 2030
working group
and the officers for their hard work
that they've got into getting the report
before members this evening
this again was presented to review
committee our last
meeting where officers answered
questions and the original
recommendations were agreed with an
amendment to one recommendation
and the addition of the 10th
recommendation
marcus hotman is present this evening
um i'm sure he'll better answer any
additional questions members may have
on this wide ranging and ongoing subject
matter
if there aren't any i recommend removing
the report for approval
um if there are any members can i just
please ask that marcus may need to get
back to you
a bit later if he's not got the answer
for them this evening thank you
thank you councillor burton
members are there any questions
counselor mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman um i would i'm
obviously
as chair of the carbon neutral working
group like to
um second um uh councillor burton
um just a couple of um comments i'd like
to echo the thanks
to um everybody who was on the carbon
neutral
working group um especially councillor
um
danielle belton and councillor craig
canal who attended
um a seminar on behalf of the group
um also to our portfolio holder for
coming to all the meetings
as an oversight as he is the portfolio
holder for the environment
um and just listening to um councillor
michael boyce
words i would again like to extend an
invitation
for any member of the green party to
come and join our working group
it will continue and we now have
um several members from several of the
minority groups unfortunately nobody has
yet from the green
and i'm sure that they would be welcome
to come and contribute
and help make the carbon neutral
um working group the group that they
feel that it should be
because i think the members have worked
very very hard on this
and the officers thank you chairman
thank you councillor mcpherson
councillor canel
thank you chair uh no no questions on
this
um just to thank councillor mcpherson
for
the kind words um and to extend my
thanks to the rest of the working group
for making it a welcoming environment to
work in
on what is a very important matter um
and as alluded to this was meant to be a
starting point not all-encompassing
and i look forward to continue working
with the group to move this forward
thank you chair thank you councillor
canel councillor mrs mason
counselor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i'm always
advising you that um
councillor high his signal had dropped
out but he's back in now so
that's all it was thank you thank you
council steptoe
thank you chairman um with regards to
there's been a lot of hard work going
into this report
and with regards to the asset review and
the asset project that is uh
coming forward can i have some
clarification that the
thoughts and ideas and suggestions that
the
carbon working group are bringing
forward will be taken into account
with the asset development programme
thank you councillor steptoe uh mr
hotton can you respond to that please
yes i can um i can confirm there's been
active conversations uh throughout the
uh
working group um i feel like uh um some
discussions
uh alongside the asset program so i'll
be discussing
with matt howard by assistant director
um
sort of our aspirations and and they
have been taken on board and we'll
continue their discussions
thank you thank you council williams
thank you chairman i would just like to
thank
all of the members that were on this
working party especially
um a.d marcus hotten and paul gowers who
did an amazing job
thank you and i do hope that this
working party continues thank you
thank you councillor williams council mr
hoy did you wish to speak
on this item
sorry chairman about my dropping out
there um i don't there's no point
repeating myself again i've said it on
the wrong item but i'm sure everyone
remembers it
so that's no problem at all thank you
counselor hi
remembers there are ten rec
recommendations arising from the report
is set out on paragraph 2.1 on pages
8.2.2 and 8.2.3
can i ask members as to whether they are
minded to vote on all recommendations on
block
please click on the hand icon if you
don't agree with this
did you wish to speak yeah there's only
one item i wouldn't take on block and
i'm happy to vote for it which i cannot
get up on my
other screen at the moment unfortunately
which was around the um
the plastic one i'm happy to take that
i'm happy to vote for that but
abstain on the others
okay it should be in the script there
members in due of uh council hoy's
comments um are you minded members to
take them
all on block except for recommendation
two again please raise your hand icon if
you don't agree with this
christine christie mason councillor mrs
mason
um mr chairman it's not a question of
not agreeing it's a question i can't get
my computer's frozen i can't get the
recommendations up
so if you could read the recommendations
then i will you know probably be able to
agree but at the moment
i can't vote on something i can't hear
or see
thank you thank you counselor mrs mason
i shall read the recommendations
recommendation one that the draft carbon
neutral policy
and action plan be approved
recommendation two that the draft
disposable plastic policy and action
plan be
three that the annual report of
greenhouse gas bracket ghg close bracket
emissions
be prepared to show that the council's
carbon footprint is
what the council's carbon footprint is i
repeat that one again
recommendation three that the annual
report of greenhouse gas
bracket ghg close bracket emissions
be prepared to show what the council's
carbon footprint is
four that all council reports include a
section
on the effect of the decision will have
on the ghg admissions of the council
five the revised procurement strategy be
prepared taking into account the issues
mentioned in the report
six that the limitations around the
current planning regulations be noted
seven that the revised local plan takes
into account the government's
environmental bill
eight that the opportunities of working
in partnership
with southend borough council and other
essex
authorities to reduce rochefort district
council's carbon footprint be explored
nine that the potential cost of a carbon
reduction
officer or other possible arrangements
such as partnership working
to deliver the initiatives in the
proposed action plan be investigate
investigated
once quantified in a request for
additional resource to be considered as
part of the budget setting process
for 2021 stroke 22
and 10 that the review committee
received an
annual update on carbon neutral by 2030.
mrs mason did you hear all those council
mrs mason did you hear all those
yes thank you mr chairman no i have got
no problem
with voting on those thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman um i was hoping to
come in before
um just as an aid member um these were
the
items exactly the same order as on the
review committee meeting last week
um of which councillor mrs mason was a
member
um it's quite an emotive subject for me
so i can always remember how people
voted if that
would help at all thank you councillor
mrs mcpherson
uh thank house and visit mrs mcpherson
for her assistance but if i can't get
documents on my machine there's nothing
i can do thank you
members we'll take a roll call for all
recommendations apart from
recommendation
two and again when i call your name if
you could
indicate whether you'd like to have a
recorded vote
whether you're voting for against or
abstaining
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote for the motions
councillor burton
no recorded vote for the motion thank
you councillor butcher
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
thank you councillor cornell
no recorded vote required for the
recommendations
counsellor mr carter no recorded vote
for the motions council mrs carter
thank you chair uh no recorded vote and
four thank you
myself councillor dre no recorded vote
and for the recommendations counselor fd
or and for councillor eves
a recorded vote and for the motion thank
you thank you councillor gooding
thank you chairman no recorded vote
and for all the motions thank you
councillor hawkway
no recorded vote and abstain thank you
cancer mr hoy uh no recording vote
chairman and
abstain and could i have my vote
recorded please as such okay
councillor hudson no recorded vote
for the motions councillor ionu
no record of votes and fought for the
emotions
councillor mr lucas gill no recorded
vote and for
thank you councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
abstain
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
thank you councillor merrick
oh and four thank you councillor meown
no recorded vote and floral emotions
thank you councillor newport
no and four thank you councillor mrs
pavling
uh no i'm four thank you councillor mrs
rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mrs shaw
no and four thank you councillor mr shaw
no and four
that's four
councilor smith no recorded vote for
thank you yeah it's just sparing no and
for
counselor stanley
no and for thank you counselor steptoe
oh and four thank you council wald
no unfortunate thank you council webb
thank you chairman no and four council
mrs watson
no recording vote and four mr wilkinson
council wilkinson
uh no recorded vote and for all of the
recommendations thank you council
williams
no recording voting for the
recommendations thank you chairman
councillor wilson no
and for council woodson
no and four thank you chairman
remembers that has been carried there
are 33 votes
four three abstentions no recorded vote
thank you
members are shown then we'll take
recommendation two
and again i would need to go through the
um
roll call if you
just to remind you recommendation two is
that the draft disposable plastic policy
and action plan be approved
please indicate when i call your name
whether you want a recorded vote
for against or abstain
counsellor mrs belton
no and four thank you councillor burton
i'll come back to you council burton
council mrs butcher
thank you chairman no and four okay
councillor burton are you there now
yes can you hear me yes we can thank you
well
uh no for a recorded vote and for
recommendation thank you councillor
canel
no and fourth chairman thank you thank
you
councillor mr carter
no i'm four thank you jim thank you
councillor mrs carter
thank you no anna abstain thank you
myself accountant dre no recorded vote
and for the recommendation
councillor fd no i'm for
thank you councillor eves no and four
thank you
councillor gooding thank you chairman no
i'm four councillor hawkway
uh no recorded vote and uh abstain
councillor mr hoy no and four thank you
chairman
councillor hudson no and four
councillor ionu no and poor
councillor lucas gill no
and for
[Music]
no and for the motion thank you
recommendation sorry thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
no and for thank you chairman thank you
councillor merrick
no and four councillor meal
no and for
[Music]
thank you chairman no and for councillor
mrs shaw
no and four thank you chairman
councillor mr shaw thank you chairman
no recorded vote for the motion thank
you councillor smith
no recorded vote for council sparing
eric could you vote for council stanley
no and four thank you thank you that's
the step
and four thank you council ward
no unfortunate councillor webb
thank you chairman no and for thank you
council
this is council mrs weston
harry according to chairman four thank
you
council mr wilkinson no one four council
williams
thank you chairman no and for the
recommendation thank you council wilson
no and for councillor woodson
no recorded vote and four
members that has been carried no
recorded vote 34 votes four
and two abstentions thank you
members i shall now take item nine on
the agenda report
on urgent decisions uh we've seen the
urgent decisions
is that noted members and again i will
assume agreement
unless anyone clicks on the raised hand
icon
[Music]
that's noted members thank you
shall now take item 10 on the agenda
report of the leader of the work of the
executive
council wooden thank you chairman
uh this is the second ordinary council
meeting
of the 2020 stroke 21 municipal year
my first as leader of the council i
would like to welcome all members
since the last meeting on the 19th of
may
the executive has met twice at its
meeting
on the 17th of june considerations
included
clarification and confirmation of the
amount
received from central government to
assist with the coronavirus situation
and how it has been allocated approval
of the provisional out-turn position
against the 2019
stroke 20 revenue budget and transfer
from business rate
smoothing reserves approval of the
transfer from the pensions reserve
and revenue carried forward requests
approval of earmarked reserves including
those rolled forward
as grant funded and ring-fenced projects
approval of capital project
carryforwards or outstanding schemes
at the end of the 2019 stroke 20
into the 2020 stroke 21 or completion
agreed a spending plan for the council's
reopening high street safely grant
funding
agreement other matters that my
executive colleagues and i have dealt
with
include agreement of a formal response
to be submitted in respect of the brad
will be consultation
on proposals for a new nuclear power
station
and also approval of the environmental
health
service plan for 2020 to 21
to comply with the food law code of
practice members i would be happy to
take any questions
in respect of the work of the executive
and i'm sure
my executive colleagues will be happy to
contribute where appropriate
thank you chairman thank you council
woodson are there any questions
members counselor mrs mason
thank you thank you mr chairman um can
you hear me because i can't
i can hear you we can hear you excellent
um
i'd like to congratulate uh councillor
woodson on delivering his first report
on his work as a leader
um he's stated that one of the
considerations
that the executive took was the
clarification
and confirmation the amount received
from central government
to assist with the corona virus
situation and how it was allocated
now i know that has been circulated a
couple of times
i'm also very aware that the circulation
of the information that was given to us
was in a draft format and we were
advised by the section 151 officer that
it would be
changing so i wondered if
that after this meeting i don't expect
the
leader to have the information to hand
but if he could
circulate that clarification and
confirmation of the latest
um allocations with the rationale behind
it to all members
thank you thank you councillor mrs mason
councillor steptoe
thank you chairman with reference to the
um
some money that essex county council has
received with regards to
cycle tracks the portfolio holder for
planning stroke transport was looking in
to
potentially putting together a um
an application to essex county council
for
grant of grant funding uh to look at our
cycle tracks uh and make improvements
in particular um what's known as the
um old roadway that runs back of um
at the new hall road development the
name escapes me
instantly i do apologize
and gem particular looking at how that
can be linked in
um to through to from rochford through
to the
uh what's known as the christmas tree
estate and also into cherry orchard park
and i asked chairman how that uh um
project is he is continuing
and um when we are likely to see the
potential of a application going forward
for to 2s county council for some of
that funding
thank you council councilwood would you
like council wall to respond to that
question
well if i can come back first to council
mrs mason's request
and of course uh we'll be happy to
circulate the latest figures
uh for uh in that respect
and chairman the once i'm very happy for
council award i think the questions are
specific to items on my
report and whilst it is a very
reasonable and appropriate
inquiry it doesn't actually relate
specifically to
the report this evening but and i think
it's iron well
lame that councillor steptoe is
referring to but uh
perhaps he could just clarification what
point that comes under within the report
who's with reference to the work of the
executive
the gem the leader mentioned at the end
of his report that uh
you'd have to take questions on the work
of the executive
and yes just to clarify it is i'm i'm
rolling
okay chairman i think uh council awards
can certainly provide an update thank
you
councilwood uh thank you chairman yeah
on regards to that uh at this moment uh
marcus hotten the id is investigating
the whole of this we have discussed
how we're going to look at the strategic
view
of cycling throughout the district and
we're looking at
lots of options which i believe i have
spoken
with councillor steptoe over the last
year
and i think he's aware of those options
um
i'm happy to pass on to uh
marcus hotten if he has an update if not
i'm sure we'll be able to provide that
update in due course
to all members thank you
mr hutton have you got an update
i think very easy to circulate an update
sir um after the meeting thank you
thank you mr hotten
council newport
thank you chairman um my question for
the leader
is that um sorry i can't i can't find um
iphone 10 report but could the leader
tell us if the any of the fifty thousand
pound um in the leaders funders had to
be used in response to the corona virus
council of warton um i'd have to
defer i don't believe it has but i'd
have to defer to councillor smith if i
may on that councillor simon smith
council smith can you respond to that
please
the council newport could just repeat
his
his inquiry again please newport can you
repeat your question
i can't mr chairman yeah um
could you um tell members if
any of the 50 000 pounds within the
leaders fund
has been used in response to coronavirus
and if so
what has it been used for
i i don't believe any ha has been spent
but
at this moment in time
thank you council smith thank you paul
for your question
councilman wilkinson record chairman
just following on from council newport's
question
um i don't know i guess that councillor
smith is probably not able to answer
this at this particular moment
um i actually put an application in um
probably march i think it was um for
funding from that fund
i was told by the section 151 officer
that obviously we have to wait until the
beginning of the new financial year
uh which was back in april now uh
naturally
well i've taken a step back because of
what's been going on with the
coronavirus but in light of the last
answer i wonder if
somebody might be able to give me an
answer uh either now or as soon as
um as to the current state of play with
applications for that fund if the
money's not gone elsewhere
thank you chairman councillor smith can
you respond to that
um it it is the leaders the leaders fund
ra
rather than mine but uh i i would point
out
that while we've been doing our best to
have business as normal uh minds
and uh energy and attention has been
focused quite rightly on other matters
thank you thank you council smith
members i can't see anybody indicating
they wish to speak i shall therefore go
on to
agenda item 11 no to motions on
notice members we have two
motions unnoticed that were deferred
from the council meeting of the 18th of
february
one from councillors canal a newport
relating to the firework
by firework campaigning has been
withdrawn from tonight's agenda
i would however propose that we take the
other proposal
by council's newport's dalian canal
relating to tree planting strategy first
is that agreed members i will assume
agreement unless anyone clicks on the
raised
hand icon
nobody that members has a group been
agreed
council newport would you like to
summarize and speak
to your motion on notice please
thank you chairman um i am
actually chairman i would like to um if
i may
i will withdraw this motion as i have
received an email
from the portfolio holder for the
environment who is
offered to work with us on this motion
and
um we will work outside of
outside of this meeting with the
assistant director
if the portfolio holder for the
environment is in agreement with that
thank you councillor newport council
williams
yeah more than happy to do so thank you
very much councillor
new newport and i look forward to
working with you thank you
thank you very much councillor williams
thank you thank you council williams
county
councillor wilson
thanks chairman can i just confirm this
is about the the
tree planting motion it is
thank you could i just say add one thing
i've fully endorsed the
the motion um but i think the other
thing
that we should look at is protecting our
existing woodland
particularly when we are developing our
new local plant
thank you chairman thank you councillor
wilson
um membership
council council wilson just to confirm
that that motion has been now been
withdrawn
by council newport okay
um members will now take um uh
the uh item the first motion
and this is in respect of
bear with me a motion on notice relating
to the system of voting
has been proposed by councillors
wilkinson eaves and our ionu
council wilkinson would you please like
to summarize and speak
on your motion of notice please thank
you chairman
uh this motion uh chairman is submitted
to full council this evening to
recognize and deal with
the desire from some members to have the
numerical results of voting
by a show of hands recorded within the
minutes of the meeting
at present the constitution does not
prevent this but it doesn't expressly
permit it
it is important to recognize that in a
democratic society there will always be
some who are in favor of a proposal and
others who are against it
chairman the current system for
recording votes with the obvious
exception of a recorded vote under
rule 17.4 does not allow the minutes of
the meeting
to reflect the difference of opinion
either shows the motion passed or failed
any member of the council or remember
the public reading those minutes will
therefore
never know if there was any division in
opinion and a natural assumption will be
that all members voted either one way or
the other
and we of course know that this is
rarely the case central governments have
a system in which they acknowledge the
division in opinion
and the votes are recorded to reflect
this whilst the minutes
must obviously reflect the final result
of a ballot and that motion will be
where it's either passed or it's failed
uh by full council this is vitally
important in my submission mr chairman
that the precise voting uh to be
represented in the minutes
which are the final record of a council
meeting for future reference
chairman therefore my proposal this
evening is that
paragraph 17.3 of the constitution
be replaced with the following unless a
recorded vote is demanded under
under rule 17.4 the chairman will take
the vote by a show of hands
and the numbers of those voting for or
against emotion or abstaining from
voting
will be recorded in the minutes thank
you chairman
thank you councillor wilkinson council
will kickstart do you have a seconder
i'd like to second at least i'll second
it
chancellor eves
members are there any questions
well thank you chairman i was just
wondering is this also
uh are you happy for this to be included
in remote meetings as well
because we don't know how long uh we're
going to
be in this situation where we are
conducting remote meetings
and you know i i think it's not
unreasonable this uh this motion
in my opinion and i'm happy to support
it
um and obviously i'd like to see
us make how can we vote far easier
going forward in remote meetings i just
wonder if
council wilkinson's thieves and
iona would be happy with that please
council will concern can you respond to
that please thank you chairman thank you
council award yeah i mean
uh you're quite right we don't know how
long we're going to be in the situation
for um to answer your question directly
my
my initial uh desire is for this to take
effect immediately
um i am aware um that
uh i don't know what goes on behind the
scenes that's currently going on next to
the chairman um and i'm not um going to
start
enforcing or trying for the us to
enforce on the democratic services
office as something which is physically
impossible so
subject to their ability um to be able
to do what we're asking of them then i
would request this as
with immediate effect thank you chairman
thank you councillor wilkinson
councillor mrs weston thank you chairman
um i understand what councillor um
wilkinson is is saying but um
i'm better believe we had a meeting with
uh
you and robin councillor robin dre with
um
sonia and uh andrew the other day
talking about how we can
set up a system of result of doing
voting which we've
we felt we were doing quite well and
that's not come to the council at the
moment but i'm just wondering whether
we'll just hang on
maybe for a while just so we find out
whether sonia and
angelique angela can then sort this one
out it's quite a good system
the way they were sorting out it's just
a thought chairman
we feel that that's unrelated to this to
this motion at
this stage okay thank you chairman would
anybody else like to speak
counselor mr hoy
sorry thank you chairman i think um just
you've just dealt with actually i was
just going to say that i think the um
the way the the voting works in the
virtual meeting seems to lend itself
quite easily
just to recall the number of votes for
and against the abstentions and the do
not vote so i think it
possibly makes it an easier way to start
anyway thank you thank you accounts to
hoi
council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i i agree with the
previous uh speaker councillor high and
i'd also
like to support the motion it's a simple
motion
it brings us into line with more senior
bodies
of democracy and it should cause no
problems
i appreciate the difficulty that
officers
and our chairman is having with the
remote voting
but i think this is a totally separate
subject and should be treated as such
and certainly i will support the motion
as it stands thank you
thank you councillor canelo
chair my um my concerns were wrapped up
with your previous comments i have since
removed
my hands thank you thank you counselor
fd
thank you chairman um i'm happy to to
support i think there was an amendment
somewhere
within all this to uh ask that the
this be taken from now with remote with
the remote
uh counting of votes and i'd be happy to
support that if
councillor wilkinson would like to
repeat the amendment which
i think councillor ward suggested
counselor fd i don't think there was an
amendment
uh to suggested by council ward it was
just a statement of fact
all right okay we've lost you chester
dre
sorry councillor i don't think
there was a amendment suggested by
council ward it was simply a statement
of fact
is that correct council awards
now it was basically looking at this uh
is this intended to start immediately
with immediate effect or wait
until we actually have meetings in the
chamber
uh we don't know how long this is going
to continue
with remote meetings so when we are
going to eventually one hopes
have a show of hands where we do have
the right hand
raising ability where it will make
voting a lot
easier and maybe help our officers
going forward it was purely to note the
factor
that if this were to happen raising
one's hand
in either um for or against
it would it would actually work quite
well that was basically it
thank you council ward i think council
wilkinson did answer that question did
you not counselor wilkinson
uh thank you chairman yes i was just
going to come back on that point because
i
i did answer that question and by saying
that um my
my desires for this to immediate to be
immediate um i mean
let's face it even in a virtual setting
the voting that we're having tonight
um which we haven't had a recorded vote
yet from memory correct me if i have
that wrong
so they all fall under paragraph 17.3 so
they're all
what we would class as a vote by show of
hands um
so it would include this type of vote so
subject to
the um the democratic service officers
physically
physically being able to do this because
i don't know what's going on behind the
scenes there and then my desire is for
this to take effect immediately thank
you jim
thank you councilor wilkinson
councillor mrs rowe thank you chairman
um just to say that i totally support
this motion as it stands thank you
councillor cannell again do you wish to
come back
uh yes chair um it was just sir to
clarify i believe there has been a
recorded vote this evening in regards
councillor wilkinson's comments um
thank you chair thank you
councillor hawkway
um yes sir just uh thank you chairman
i'd just like to
say that uh there seems a sensible
inspiration to the constitution
and should actually make life
easier for yourself and for
recording the votes in future thank you
very much thank you councillor hook
members i cannot uh note any anybody
else wishing to
uh speak on this uh motion um
there will now be i shall put the motion
to the vote
members there will now be a roll call of
names and again you know the procedure
and when i call your name please
indicate whether you want a recorded
vote
or if you're voting for or against the
motion or if you wish to abstain
counselor mrs belton no recorded vote
for the motion councillor burton
no recorded vote for the motion council
mrs butcher thank you chairman no
recorded vote
and for the motion councillor canal
thank you chair no and paul thank you
councillor mr carter
no recorded vote and ford emotion thank
you so mrs carter
thank you um recorded vote please and
for this motion and well done guys
myself councillor drano recorded vote
and for the motion
council orton iv chairman
thank you councillor eves
for recorded votes and for the motion
thank you thank you councillor mrs
gooding
a recorded vote and for the motion thank
you chair
thank you councillor mr hookway
thank you chairman uh for recording and
for the motion
thank you councillor mr hoy paul
recorded voting for the motion thank you
chairman
councillor hudson no recorded vote in
favor of the motion
thank you councillor ionu four for
a recorded vote and fall for the motion
thank you councillor mr lucas gill
no and four thank you councillor mrs
lumley
no and for councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman for a recorded
vote
and support the motion thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
uh no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
councillor merrick no and four
councillor meal no recorded vote and for
the motion
council newport four and four please
counselor mrs pavling uh
no i'm four thank you councillor mrs
rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
account for mrs shaw
thank you mr chairman known for
councillor mr shaw known for
thank you councillor smith and recorded
vote
for council sparing no and for
thank you council stanley four
and four please for recorded vote yes
thank you
it's council steptoe
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you council ward
no and for councillor webb
thank you chairman no and for the motion
councillor mrs weston very cool
development for the motion chairman
thank you
council wilkinson known for chairman
thank you councillor williams
thank you chairman no and for the motion
thank you council wilson
yeah yes and for councillor
thank you gentlemen no i'm four thank
you
members no recorded vote oh my
my apologies members there is a recorded
vote and the vote
was unanimous for the motion
members i shall now take the no next
motion on notice this is relating to the
front desk at raley police station
having been proposed by council steptoe
and mrs rowe
council steptoe would you like to
summarize and speak on your motion of
notice please
thank you chairman yes thank you very
much indeed um
i'll introduce the uh the motion but i
will hold the reserve the right to speak
at the end of the debate
if so necessary i'm sure
most people will realize that uh if you
need to uh
go and speak to the police at the front
desk the only options you have currently
at the moment is either to go to south
end or
basildon which is not really
um very useful for certainly people
that living out outline areas there's a
strong campaign
um coming forward to reopen the
desk at rady police station
the does not necessarily need to be
with frontline police but can be
dealt with by um civilian
workers whether they be volunteers or or
not
so therefore the motion that i'm
proposing that this council fully
supports the campaign
and calls on the priest and fire
crime commissioner and the chief
constable to reopen the public front
desk
at rady police station and for its beat
officers to hold regular
bi-weekly meetings for the public to
attend
at key venues around the district
thank
council mrs rowe thank you chairman um i
will second that motion
um but i'd just like to add with such a
big police station in raleigh
the expectation of the public is that
the front desk is open
members of the public just need
reassurance in my opinion
this could be for a trial period
monitoring the reasons for visits to
this station
and and doesn't necessarily have to be
all day it could be
five mornings a week or depends on
depending on their staff situation
um so yes i totally second this motion
thank you
thank you councilman mrs rowe council
wilkinson
thank you chairman i'm going to start by
saying i fully support this
fully support this motion um and i will
be voting in favor of it but i've got a
couple of questions which perhaps counts
as a step to a councillor could answer
um having been a serving officer in es6
at the time that radio police station
front desk was shut as were a lot of the
others i i
i'm sort of um i've seen what's gone in
the background and the reasons why and
so therefore i mean
perhaps i'm i'm a little bit more aware
of the uphill struggle is going to be to
try and
achieve this um and i so two questions
really
um it's interesting that council steptoe
mentioned volunteers because i know that
there has been
some interest from uh parties in the
past who've approached its police to do
exactly that and
they were somewhat hesitant so um i i do
hope that's
something that could go forward um but i
just i just wonder
what um contact has been made with the
local
um police so particularly someone like
chief respect to dave miles who's the
local police and commander
with regards to these bi-weekly meetings
um they already hold some meetings but
they're certainly not frequent enough
um and if they've got the resources to
do that and i just wonder what sort of
background inquiries have been done um
like i said
i fully support this i'm not trying to
put a spanner in the works and i want to
really help make this work and i'll be
interested to work with the guys doing
this but
um i suppose i'm just putting a slightly
realistic uh covering over it having
only recently retired from the force
myself so i know what the strains are
thank you chairman
cancer steptoe would you like to respond
to that chairman if i may
um there are a number of other questions
if i can uh take the quote or
hear all the questions then i'll come
back and answer all the questions at the
same time we'll come back to you count
to step two thanks
council award
thank you chairman um yeah i think it's
very very important
that this office is open um
the police do need to be front-facing
um we need to be able to to actually see
them
and see them about and we need to be
able to contact them and i think
you know the police also need to have
good public relations
that's very very important and i think
this is all part of it they need to
understand
that um i i guess as as councillor
wilkinson
has just said as a newly retired police
officer
i think he understands the constraints
that are there
but i also believe that sometimes they
can be a dreadful
excuse for for not actually doing what
is needing and i know that
pr is not something probably
the police are necessarily famous for
but i think it would really really help
to give confidence to residents
and and i think opening up this front
office
albeit it may be volunteers pcsos
or or other officers who are available
will really give a tremendous
encouragement
to the public in regards to the police
thank you and i'm going to fully support
this as well
thank you thank you council ward council
newport
thank you chairman um yeah i think we've
all heard from
uh police fire crime commissioner um
saying he prefer
officers on the street as opposed to in
a building but i fully support this
motion that's being put forward
by council step term councillor ro i
think residents are fed up with playing
hunt the policeman and um i think that
they should there should be somewhere
they can go and have face-to-face
contact
with a representative from the police
and i think it would be
very reassuring for residents to know
where they can go
and it helps required
seek it so i will be fully supporting
this motion
thank you council newport councillor
canal
thank you cheer um yes i would like to
to thank the councillors uh councillor
steptoe and and councillor mrs rowe for
bringing this forward i also fully
support this
um one thing councillor black taught me
way back when is if you
would like support from someone try not
to offend them
and with that in mind i would however
propose to we
give the chief constable his proper
title when passing this motion
thank you chair thank you councillor
cannell
councillor mr hoy thank you chairman
um yeah i studied this motion with
interest i i will support it
but i i just have concerns about
volunteers yet again
been used to fulfill
bloodline duties which should be paid
for
i again fail to understand why
the conservative pfcc doesn't actually
speak to the um
conservative members here and again
perhaps the conservative members should
reflect on the fact that twenty thousand
police officers have
been cut and that may have some bearing
on why the um
office at rady is closed but i will
support this motion thank you
thank you councillor hi councilman mrs
belton
thank you chair um just uh just a couple
of points really i fully support the
motion i think it would be
great for the district to have a front
desk open again
but i would just like to say personally
during covid or throughout kovid i've
really noticed an increased
amount of police officers on the street
and it's been welcomed
by members of the public um they've done
number of live q a
online facebook sessions over the last
few months
and before all area based which have
seemed to be really well received and
really
um easy to use and finally
throughout the last few months i've
really felt the police have been
reactive to
areas of complaints and concerns around
the district
and have done a good job in putting in
stock to some anti-social behavior
that's been happening
thank you thank you councillor mrs
belton
councilman oh yes i
fully support this uh this idea but we
always have an opportunity because the
the roger hurst actually has had
some progressive and um
innovative ideas in essex and
i went up to see the specials being
sworn in and they were quality people
that he'd selected and the idea of
volunteers who don't want to be a
special but
want to be part of the community could
we explore
new ways of managing this not just
expecting someone to be propped up
behind a desk and the guy goes shuffling
in through the door
but rather if we look at what's going on
in glasgow for example
they're using people in the community
sometimes i know
we're not a high crime area so we
haven't really got a problems at glasgow
but there's an opportunity because there
are youth schemes there's all kinds of
things going on there's an opportunity
to look at this sort of volunteers
and it is a facility you've got that
large building and there's uh
council steptoe says you've got to go an
awful long way to see someone face to
face
um so i think it's got value and it
needs exploring and if it does come back
then it needs monitoring to see that
it's you know it's actually
doing what we think it would do and
that's all i have to say on it thank you
thank you councilman councillor
thank you chairman i certainly welcome
this motion proposed by councillor
steptoe uh really welcome it
because it is all about providing
reassurance
it is totally unacceptable to me that
there is a building in the center of a
large town
and it is known as a police station and
yet
members of the public cannot get in
there
i believe that is totally unacceptable
this is about the reassurance
it's about providing a signposting
service to members of the public
the old reasons why people used to pop
into a police station
have long disappeared but let us not
forget
there's a two-way process here it is
about providing intelligence
often people walking by a police station
will drop in
and provide a bit of information about
local issues
and local crime and that is of huge
value to the police locally
and we shouldn't overlook that factor in
terms of volunteers there is a system
within
the policing service of police support
volunteers psv's
and it is an established system and my
view is if people actually want to serve
their community in that way
that is not exploiting volunteer labor
it is actually
allowing them to be part of the
community they want to serve and i see
no difference with people doing that
sort of work compared with working in
the community
hub you just attract volunteers to do
what they would most like to do provided
that they are
suitable and in terms of numbers yes
um we know why there was a need to
reduce numbers but i applaud
the police fire and crime commissioner
for the fact that his creative approach
has actually brought essex police
numbers back to
probably near record levels certainly
around the three and a half thousand
mark
and i believe the figures were about
three thousand six hundred that maximum
accepting that they did drop to two
thousand eight hundred but i think
that we should be very proud of what has
actually happened uh so i
certainly support the uh uh motion and i
welcome councillor stepcode's
proposals thank you thank you councillor
watson council steptoe would you like to
come back
on the question raised by council
wilkinson yes thank you
chairman uh yes i had had some
discussions with
uh um the local chief inspector
um david miles some some time ago now
um it probably goes back to the
beginning of the year
uh with regards to increasing the number
of uh
public meet public facing meetings that
police could attend
but don't forget this is part of a much
larger campaign that is being brought
forward with regards to
the the station itself
with regards to the volunteers um yes
the
we volunteers like to do all sorts of
different things
and i think we've been shown over the
last few months
how much people do want to volunteer to
help their community
just one particular note was that uh we
say there is no public access to
the radio police station that is correct
through the front door
um but there are occasions where the
public are taking you through the back
door
not necessarily willingly they do
but uh i do think it's important that we
go back to the uh
police and fire and crime commissioner
and ask him to really consider this as
as an option
to look at what he can actually do
working with the chief customer
and actually see what we can do so i
moved the motion that is on printed on
page
11. three item 1.5
thank you councillor steptoe council
wilkinson
chairman thank you for letting me come
back um i just wanted to make it clear
that because
i'm a conscious that maybe my comments
came across negatively and i didn't want
them to because i fully support this
um i'm just trying to be a realist i
suppose um
could i just ask him just in light of
what council scepter has just said that
when
the approach the pfcc is made that we
have to be clear that we want him to try
and do his best to try
and increase the numbers down here
because what we obviously don't want and
i'm sure all members agree
is to have lots of nice meetings and
people
in front offices but to the detriment of
officers on the streets
um because officers need to be on the
streets so obviously he needs to
increase the
the establishment down here if he can
and i would i would
uh urge that's the approach that we take
with him thank you jen
thank you council wilkinson councillor
canal
thank you chair very small point um uh
the the text reads uh
chef constable if we could change it to
chief constable i'd be
more than happy to support this thank
you
council steptoe do you agree with that
small change
kevin yes and i took it just as a um a
typo shall we say within the
in the in the paperwork i'm sure thank
you
um i'm sure he is a very good chef but
i've yet to
um counselling mrs rowe
you're muted councillor
thank you chairman it's clearly a typo
so yes if that can be changed that'd be
good thank you
thank you members i don't see anybody
else um indicating they wish to speak
so members uh i shall put the emotion to
the vote
subject at that minute change that has
been mentioned by councillor canal
and as you know members we shall have a
roll call of names when i call your
names please indicate whether you wish
to
have a recorded vote for against and
wish to abstain
councillor mrs belton
recorded vote for the motion thank you
council mrs butcher
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
councillor canel no and for
chair thank you councillor mr carter
no recording and for a motion councillor
mrs carter
thank you um recorded please and four
myself councillor drayno recorded vote
and four
councillor fd now and for
councillor eves no recorded vote and
four thank you
councillor mrs gooding no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you mr chairman
thank you councilman
our recorded vote and for the motion
thank you thank you councillor
no recorded voting for the motion thank
you chairman thank you councillor mr
hudson
no recording votes and for the motion
thank you councillor ionu
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor mr lucas gill
no and four thank you councillor mrs
lumley
oh thank you councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
and i support the motion thank you
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson no
recorded vote and for the motion
thank you council merrick
council merrick
i'll come back to you mr councillor
merrick
where is he he's gone
council newport no recorded vote and for
the motion
council no recorded vote and for the
motion
councilor mrs pavlin
no i'm four thank you councillor mrs
rowe
thank you chairman no and for councillor
mrs shaw
thank you chair no and four
councillor mr shaw no and for
councillor mr smith i recorded vote for
thank you counselor sparing no for
councillor stanley no
no no n4 council steptoe
no and four council award
no and four chairman councillors
councillor webb
thank you chairman no and for councillor
mr
thank you council williams thank you
chairman no and for
councillor wilson no and for
chairman council woodson thank you
gentlemen no
i'm four i should try councillor merrick
once again
councilman eric still with us
he's waiting
you can't
we don't know how much
members i'm not sure if council america
missed any of the debate
um uh the motion has been passed uh no
recorded vote and
34 voted for thank you very much members
members who now go on to the next motion
on notice this is relating to the
or environment bill and has been posed
by council
mrs mcpherson and councillor mrs gooding
council mrs mcpherson would you please
summarize and speak on your motion of
notice
thank you chairman um
the environment bill's already been
mentioned this evening
um in actual fact um motion seven of the
carbon neutral report
actually mirrors uh one of the
recommendations
um for this motion um
i was a little bit bemused earlier the
environment bill
can make such an impact on our local
community
and the future local plan and yet
not all members voted for that motion
so i'm just going to run through my
motion here
and hopefully gain some support from
members i originally submitted it by the
way on the 11th of march
hence there was a crossover with the
carbon neutral
report so last year our government led
the way in being the first national
government to declare
an environment and climate emergency
aiming to be carbon neutral by 2050.
our own authority has set up a carbon
neutral working group specifically to
identify how we can reduce our carbon
footprint
and aim to become carbon neutral
we now have the emerging environment
bill
which will bring into uk law
environmental protections and recovery
the environment bill will put the
environment
at the center of policy making it will
make sure that we have a cleaner
greener and more resilient country for
the next generation
this will provide new developments that
enhance bio
diversity and create new green spaces
for local communities to enjoy so this
council is currently working on
preparing a new local plan
i propose that the environment bill is
at the center of this new plan
and also that the council lobbies the
secretary of state
to ensure that the national planning
policy
framework and the planning advisory
service
adopts the aims of the environment bill
within their policy
framework thank you chairman and may i
reserve the right to speak at the end of
debate
thank you councillor mrs macpherson mrs
council mrs mcpherson do you have a
seconder
who is he's julie gooding
councillor gooding thank you councillor
gooding can confirm that please
yes thank you chairman um as part of the
carbon neutral working group um
i can see how important it is for
a whole cross-party support for this
motion
as without adoption by the secretary of
state
into the nppf that's the national
planning policy framework
and the planning advisory service we
will have problems in
enforcing any change so i
second this motion thank you councillor
gooding
councillor why
thank you chairman um i will be sporting
this motion
um i will make a couple of comments
though because um councilman
mcpherson has made a couple of
points which i think are directed
towards me
um i will point out that the
seven item or recommendation seven
on item eight two just said
takes into account the government's
government's environment bill
and that's the point i was trying to
make it's not very
forceful take into account could mean
anything um
whereas this motion is much much better
it says we actually do something
which is why i always fought it
obviously i've got a few problems with
the environment bill they may change or
they may not but what
even at the moment as it stands i'm very
happy
to support it being at the center of our
planning policy and i welcome
this council liaising or inputting into
any changes to that environment bill and
i'm very happy to support it thank you
thank you council mr high council mrs
mason
thank you mr chairman i welcome
this motion i think um
it's probably well overdue but
unfortunately so is the environment bill
and as much as i support this and i do
support it wholeheartedly
i think we need a minor change and if
councilman pearson will bear with me
i will explain why the environment
bill itself was delayed in 2019
the sittings have been suspended because
of
the pandemic so it's delayed
yet again the committee report
itself isn't actually due until late
autumn
now bearing in mind the difficulties
that
parliament can find itself in and the
difficulties that the country may find
itself in
there is a possibility or even a
probability i don't know
i'm not a psychic um that this bill will
not be passed
therefore this there's two um items
to council mcpherson's and councillor
gooding's
promotion one is that this council
lobbies the secretary of state to ensure
that the national
planning policy framework and planning
and advisory service
adopts the aims of the environmental
bill
within their policy framework and i
wholeheartedly support that
i couldn't support it more the slight
problem i have
and perhaps if i explain because of the
potential difficulties and delays that
this council is
currently working on preparing a new
local plan i i know we're the emerging
local planning is quite topical at the
moment
i propose that the environment bill is
at the center of this new plan
the problem i have with that is that we
are trying to get our local plan through
as quickly as possible the environment
bill
may be later can i suggest
and ask if counselor mrs mcpherson will
consider
just putting the two words into that
first
sentence that the aims so that it
doesn't isn't held up
so that the local plan can then endorse
it with the aims of the environmental
bill
rather than the bill because if the
bill's not passed
we're in a difficult situation i know
it's semantics i know it's difficult but
i'm trying to be constructive
and i hope that the comments that i've
made will be taken in that way
but certainly i support the motion thank
you
so would you like to comment on that
councillor mrs mcpherson would you like
to comment on that yes thank you
chairman sorry i was just unmuting
should i be totally candid um i just
wonder why uh councilman mrs mason has
left
it until this evening to raise this this
could have been brought to us earlier
behind the scenes as you know other
groups including other minority groups
have been working collaboratively so if
a motion is put forward
and they have something to add to it or
add value to it
they've actually come to that person and
had a conversation
instead of leaving it until we've got a
very
big um agenda to bring it up at full
council
and i'm not quite sure why councillor
mrs mason does this
i am quite happy to add those two words
in i'm merely pointing out
how much easy it would have been if that
was put to me
yesterday a day ago or even this morning
thank you chairman thank you councillor
mrs mcpherson council ward
can i come back on that please mr
chairman
are you allowing mrs mason uh councillor
mrs mason to speak first
are you happy for that council award yes
i am council mrs mason you may speak
councillor mrs mason
there's a very simple explanation to the
implied criticism
that's been levelled at me is that as
the officers are aware that a customary
have paper copies unfortunately due to
the new working
arrangements that the council has had to
impose on us i don't
my my computer system and my technology
isn't always up
to the information i have so i don't get
the information necessary in a timely
fashion
and i don't get it in a fashion that i
can always access
the reason that i haven't been able to
access this is because it came out in a
fashion that i couldn't open it
until today so that's the reason
councilman pearson it was nothing to do
with
a lack of willingness to support you
but it was a lack of the technology
that is supporting the council at the
moment and i hope that explains the
problem that you have thank you
mr mrs base
mayor chairman just respond
um sorry councillor mrs mason
do you have a seconder for your slight
amendment
i i'm happy to second that chairman you
are okay
thank you mrs mcpherson thank you
chairman and just as a point of order
could i just um
re-mention that this motion was put
forward
back in march so it has been
in all of our councillors hands for
quite some considerable time
until it's now come forward post covered
thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson uh for the sake
of clarity
can you please confirm exactly where
you'd like
the amendments to be made
sorry councillor mrs mason my apologies
councillor mrs mason
should i help chair if uh council mrs
mason's having problems
can you not hear me we can hear you yes
can you please clarify
council mrs mason exactly where you'd
like the amendments to be made
it was just two words um to
ensure that this is adopted let me go
through
i'm sorry i've got it on screen it takes
me a long time to get these
things in the right place you'll have to
bear with me
my internet isn't as speedy as one would
like
that on the first proposal it's not
numbered but it's got a hyphen in front
of it this council is currently working
on preparing a new local pro plan
i propose that the aims of
simple as that the same same as um
the second one so it would be the aims
of the environment bill is at the center
as opposed to the environment bill
purely to
in case the bill isn't passed in the
sequential faction sequentially
may i just um say that it's actually
three words um chairman so it will read
on the first part of the proposal i
promised that
the aims of the environment bill
if we're being pedantic it's two words
it's aims of but don't worry about
it right
council mrs mcpherson are you happy for
those changes to be made
just i am chair thank you thank you
council award thank you chairman
yeah that's the ward can i say we're now
speaking on the amendment um yes
i'm speaking on on the amendment and the
bill i think it doesn't actually change
what time what i want to say anyway
in reality
you know because we expect the
government uh to shortly publish
a plenty white paper but to set out its
ideas and proposals
for the future of the planning system
the council's response
to this white paper will make clear its
desire to see
environmental sustainability placed at
the heart
of the planning system in practice
this will mean taking measures to ensure
that new homes
and commercial buildings minimize their
use of carbon
not just in construction but throughout
their lifetime
which is where modular build could be
promoted
together with ensuring that areas of
environmental value are afforded the
strongest
possible protection throughout the
planning system
and looking forward to the nppf
taking the environment bill into its
very heart thank you jim
councillor wilkinson can i remind you
councillor wilkinson that we're debating
the amendment
is put forward by councillor mrs mrs
mason
okay chairman i was just going to ask a
question regarding the actual motion
um as opposed to just the two words are
amended so
am i permitted to ask a question about
the motion
uh is it to do with your mended as
motion i don't think it's changed what i
was going to say knowing that's a tool
please carry on then thank you
this may well be a question for marcus
actually and i wholeheartedly support
this i think it's a fantastic idea and
and totally welcome it and listening to
the concerns have been raised with
regards to the timing of the environment
bill
i think of relevance my question i was
going to ask
is around legislation sometimes certain
parts of legislation
legislation trumps others um we're
asking for the amc environment bill to
be included within
our local plan now
my question is do we have to when we
when we are devising our new local plan
and bringing it about do we have to
stick with what the mppf
says or for example if
the aims of the environment bill even if
it was still a bill and not an act
if those aims are at odds with the mppf
which one trumps which one wins does
that make sense
uh thank you council wilkinson i can
clarify if marcus doesn't understand
sorry
okay uh mr mr marcus harden can i ask
you to respond to them
if you're able yes i'll try it's a
slightly hypothetical question
you put together there i mean um
the national um sort of um planning
policy framework
would really have the most weight in
this situation but i mean
but in many ways you know the um
uh the bill would i i guess if there's
anything significant within the bill
that would
alter how planning is to be um uh if you
like um
the policies are sort of weighed up then
it'd be reflected in changes to the mppf
anyway
if that makes sense so what i'm saying
is you you wouldn't
you wouldn't to have a nod to the bill
you'd expect the national planning
policy framework to have a have a
non-environment building itself
so it's not for us to necessarily um
shape our policy around
around that in that sense but actually
it's a national policy
of the uh planning framework to to um
give us the steer
but that's where the weight would be so
so in in a sense um
um council syndrome already already
answered his own question
when he put that that way thank you
thank you
i think that that does answer the
question councillor hudson
and council hudson can i remind you that
we are debating the amendment has put
forward by
mrs counts councillor mrs mason
thank you uh may i ask for the opinion
of uh
our md sean strutton who in the past i
have spent uh
many happy hour discussing the wording
of these things and how it could
possibly affect
our plans um i would really like his
opinion on the proposed word in relative
to
the preparation of our new local plan
um could it be detrimental in any way is
there a better form of words
i i trust shawn's opinion on that
chairman happy to comment i see no
particular reason why it should be
detrimental to the preparation of the
local plan it seems to me that
as uh as marcus hutton has
indicated the the environment will
will make a close reference
to the national planning policy
framework i think the government
has been lobbied heavily in relation to
the contents of the environmental
the environment built by the uh the rtpi
and other
uh relevant planning bodies to ensure
that the nppf will
ultimately become modified in a way that
reflects the demands
and desires of the of the environment
bill should that come into legislation
and all is well
chairman you're you're muted thank you i
can't see anybody else wishing to speak
on the amendment i shall therefore
um put the to the vote the amendment
um as uh proposed by councillor
uh mrs mason
councillor williams you wish to speak
thank you chairman just for
clarification
as mrs macpherson councillor mrs
first is happy to amend her um
motion is there a need to vote on the um
on the amendment just for clarification
please
yes uh council council williams i
understand
yes there has been an amendment we need
to vote on that amendment
okay thank you okay um so members i
shall put to the vote the amendment is
put
forward by uh councillor mrs mason and
uh seconded by councillor
mrs mcpherson and just for clarification
um this penultimate paragraph of 1.6
is now amended to read as follows
this council is currently working on
preparing a new local plan
i propose that the aims of the
environment bill
is at the center of this new plan so
we're including
the words aims of the
okay um members unfortunately that needs
to be done via a roll call
if you can indicate whether you wish to
have a recorded vote for or against or
abstain
when i read your name
counselor mrs belton no
and for thank you councillor mrs butcher
no and for thank you councillor canel
no and four thank you chair councillor
mr carter
no and four thank you councillor mrs
carter
thank you no and for the amended motion
thank you
thank you i can't myself cancer dre no
recorded vote and for the amendment uh
councillor
mr fd no and for
council mrs gooding
thank you chairman no and for the
amendment
councillor eaves no and for the
amendment
thank you chad councillor hookway
um no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
council mr hoyer
so i think you think mr hawaii i think
rather than all
um no to a recording vote and for the
amendment thank you chairman
councillor
mrs lumley no and from
councillor mrs mason no recorded vote mr
chairman
and four thank you councillor mrs
mcpherson
no and four thank you chairman thank you
councilman merrick
councillor merrick he's out he's out
i'll come back to you kenneth and
merrick cows to meal no
and for council newport
no and for councillor mrs pavlin
no i'm
thank you councillor mr shaw
mr
counselor missy shaw no and four
councillor mr shaw no i'm for
council smith no recorded vote
for
council sparing both for
council stanley no
and full council steptoe
no and four councillor ward
no and four challenge councillor webb
no and four chairman councillor mrs
weston
very cordy thank you council wilkinson
no in four chairman councillor williams
chairman no and four council wilson
no and four thank you council woodson
no i'm for chairman thank you
just to let you know that council
america appears to be back with us
thank you council wilkinson i am indeed
german you're muted counselor merrick
can i have your um vote then please on
the amendment has put
forward to by mrs christine mason and
seconded by mrs mcpherson
no and four chairman thank you
councillor merrick
members will come back
this is listen you wish to speak
mrs mason uh thank you mr chairman yes
it's a council mrs mason
i believe i owe some missing person of
an apology
i've just realized uh the difficulties i
have with my computer and the internet
and
trying to read things off of the screen
which unfortunately uh officers can't
um overcome is um
i think i miscounted i think she was
right it's three words so my apologies
i didn't mean to be inaccurate thank you
thank you councillor mrs
the vote is for the amendment 35 votes
for
and none against and no recorded vote
thank you members
that has been passed
mrs mcpherson do you wish to um speak on
your motion
you reserved the right to do so
the amendment thank you chairman all i
would say is
thank you very much councillors um i
just made a couple of notes um
uh council ahoy you mentioned that you
did not support that motion earlier
under the carbon um neutral report um
just a reminder that could have been
amended at review
or even earlier this evening as well um
and i will extend once more that
invitation to join the carbon neutral
working group
but thank you all for voting for it
thank you
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson sorry
chairman mike i'll come back on that
oh god very quickly
that comment i think that is completely
out of order if someone is saying for
god's sake
that's totally unacceptable and i want
to know who said it
are we not about to speak now
i don't know who said it counselor
thank you i also heard that comment as
well and it's not acceptable
who was that bespoke just now
council hi um i agree with your comments
but i cannot at this stage indicate
who said those words and i didn't hear
them when they originally spoken
so we if we shall move on with the
agenda
sorry i was going to say something
someone said for god's sake
i understand your point no one is owning
up to it
which i find appalling behavior by any
counsellor
i'm not going to participate in this
meeting now people are going to say that
to me
members i shall now go on to 1.7
on page 11.3 this is the um
last notice motion on notice
we need to vote on the motion oh my
apologies
with the amendment
members my apologies i now need to
vote we now need to vote on the amen on
the
motion with the amendments okay
does anybody wish me to read out the
amendments again
no okay right again i shall go through
the
roll call
thank you chair uh just um
i believe a point of order potentially a
point of clarification
um on two instances in um
council meetings in the not too distant
past
when amendments have been amended um the
the motion then goes through as an
amended motion um for example the eu
motion that was passed in february
there wasn't an opportunity to come back
and vote on the motion its
originality it was then passed as an
amended motion
so i'd like clarity on the difference
between an amended motion
and an amendment to a motion if i may
please thank you chair
councillor cannell we're struggling to
um
uh uh understand exactly your meaning
uh i thank you i'll rephrase i guess um
the question quite simply is what is the
difference between an amended motion and
an amendment
to emotion um on previous occasions when
opposition members have put forward
motions
uh when it is then voted on um pending
an emotion
an amendment that is then passed as an
amended motion there's not an
opportunity to come back
and discuss the original motion and vote
on that original motion
so it's just a point of clarity on the
difference between an amended motion
and an amendment to emotion thank you
chair
councillor connell one thing i would
suggest is that council mrs
mason suggested a very small
change to the original motion as agreed
by councillor
was put forward by councillors
macpherson and gooding
and councillor macpherson seconded that
very small
motion okay which had to be
voted on as an amendment to the original
motion
all right which was agreed by members
unanimously
i can't comment on what had gone on in
the past
at this stage but i now need to put
forward um the motion the original
motion 1.6
with the amendments as agreed by
councillors
mrs mason and councillors councillor
macpherson
which i shall now do members
i hope that's all clear if i can uh read
your name out if you can
indicate whether you wish to have a
recorded vote
or voting for against or abstain
councillor mrs belton
no four councillor mrs butcher
no and four thank you chairman
councillor canel
councillor canelo
um no recorded votes um
it's a difficult one i i wish
i feel like i'm in an understandable
position here um
going back to the the previous point um
is it just the size of the amendment
that constitutes
whether it's an amendment to a motion or
an amended motion
i very much wish to support this item
however my confusion
um has given me doubts as to whether i
should indeed abstain
um council canal i think that um
a fuller explanation can be given after
this meeting
if you're not 100 sure i would suggest
you abstain at this stage
a point of order please mr chairman
councillor uh mrs mason your point of
order
point of order is that when an amendment
is passed
the original motion is not put
the amended motion is carried therefore
sorry about this mr chairman mrs mate
class and mrs mason you're incorrect
we've actually got the constitution in
front of me page 4.12
point d if an amendment is carried the
motion as amended takes the place of the
original motion
this becomes a substantive substantive
motion
to which any other further emotion any
further
amendments are moved point e after the
amendment has been carried the chairman
will read out the emitted motion
before accepting any further amendments
or if there are none put the put it to
the vote which we are doing now
thank you no it's the um you've misread
it
to the vote i'm sorry it's a point of
order is the
any other amendments there are no
further amendments
you can't vote for one thing and then
vote for something that's different
um it it's the same thing it's very
similar
um we've had there's two ways of doing
this
and unfortunately i believe that what
you're the
you're doing now is totally wrong
councilman
unconstitutional we have a monitoring
officer
who i'm sure well i think i'll give up
okay councillor miss councillor mrs
mason
we have voted on your amendment which
has been agreed
uh which is now the substantive motion
and i'm asking members to vote on the
substantive motion which is a motion
put forward by yourselves with
amendments and agreed by councillor
macpherson
i hope members that is clear mr chairman
it's already been voted on
so the motion was originally put forward
by council mrs macpherson of which
council mrs
mason made um a slight amendment to
uh one part of the motion members then
voted to agree to accept that motion the
amendment to the motion
and now that uh those amendments become
part of the substantive motion
exactly what i said you cannot amend a
motion which
negates the original motion
no i accept that thank you yes the
monitoring obviously i
understand what you're saying but it
wasn't it's certainly not clear
and unfortunately there has been um
inconsistencies in the past which makes
it really difficult
for this to be clear so if you want to
put it again that's fine
so we're thank you
so chairman i i'm not clear as i'm still
not clear as to
uh council canals uh question but if the
original
mover had amended their own emotion
that's be surprising
that's different but i can take any
questions outside of this meeting
after this meeting from the council
canal thank you councillor canel
as i said earlier we will respond to
your questions outside of this meeting
but the amended motion um
with the amendments of mrs uh christine
mason
agreed by councillor macpherson now
becomes a substantive motion
and i'm now going to put a vote onto
that
um when your name is called please
indicate whether you're for
against or wish to abstain i shall start
again
councillor mrs belton
no i'm four thank you mrs butcher
no and four thank you chairman
councillor canel
thank you chair if this wasn't uh such
an important
um subject matter i think out of
principle i would be abstaining however
since that is now on public records
and i do feel this is an important
subject matter i will vote for
i don't require a recorded vote thank
you chair
thank you counselor carter
no and for thank you councillor mrs
carter thank you no an abstain
i'm a counselor dre that's myself no
recorded
vote and for the motion counselor ft
no recording voting for the motion
counselor eavesd
no recording vote for the motion thank
you councillor gooding
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for the motion
thank you councillor hookway
no recorded vote and uh for the united
merchant thank you jimmy
councillor mr hoy is no longer with us i
understand
councillor hudson no and four
councillor ionu no recorded vote
and four councillor mr lucas gill
no and for chairman councillor mrs
lumley
no and form councillor mrs mason
no and for councilman
councillor mrs mcpherson no and four
thank you chairman
counselor merrick no and four
councillor milne no and four
councillor newport
no and for councillor mrs pavling
uh no i'm four thank you councillor mrs
rowe
thank you chairman now and for
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman known for counseling
mr shaw
known for
mr smith i recorded vote for
council sparing no for
council stanley no and for
council steptoe
that's
uh no for a recorded vote and for the
motion
and can i remind you of the time thank
you
council ward no and four chairman
councillor webb thank you chairman no
and four
councillor mrs weston i recorded four
council wilkinson no recorded voting for
the motion chairman
councillor williams no and four thank
you
council wilson no
and four
i'm chairman this is councillor hoya i
think you said i left the meeting i
didn't i dropped out
i would never be so rude as to leave a
meeting without advising you
i'm not sure if you called me to vote or
not
muted chairman
you've got muted chairman
councillor hawaii do you wish to vote on
this item
yes i said i didn't say i wouldn't vote
i said i would not take no part in the
discussion i think can i
have your vote then please uh no for
recorded vote and for
thank you
remember so the vote for the substantive
motion
is been accepted 34 votes forward one
abstention abstention thank you very
much
members uh the time is ten o'clock and
as required i need to put
to a vote as to whether uh members
wish to extend the meeting
um we have one other
motion and the two other items to go
through
um so if i can when i go
again read your name if you can indicate
to me whether you'd like to have a
recorded vote
for or against or wish to abstain
counsellor mrs belton
no and for thank you
counselors counselor mrs butcher
no and for
mr carter no and for
councillor mrs carter
no and against myself counselor dre
no recorded vote for an extension
counselor
fd known for
councillor eves now and against
councillor gooding
no i'm four thank you chairman
councillor hawkway
no and against councillor hudson
oh i'm four councillor ionu
no and four chairman i i am still here
sorry counselor yeah my apologies
council ahoy
no and against thank you chairman
council hudson please i've given my vote
but i'll give it to you again
um no and four thank you councillor ionu
also uh no and four
councillor lucas gill no
and four councillor mrs lumley
no and against councillor mrs mason
no uh recorded vote and
against extending the meeting
mrs mcpherson
oh and four councillor merrick
no and four councillor milne
no and four
row
no and for chairman thank you councillor
mrs shaw
known for councillor mr shaw
known for
council smith no recorded vote for
council sparing no and against
council stanley no
and against and i'll bid you good night
all counselor steptoe
no and for council ward
no and four thank you council webb
no and for councillor mrs weston
thank you council williams no one
against
thank you chairman council wilson
no and against councillor woodson
no one four but a point of order please
okay
at 22.05 i just wonder how valid this
vote is
thank you
thank you
uh
b
remember there's no recorded vote we
will extend 25 votes four
and ten against thank you members
chairman sorry i can't sit here any
longer
i'm gonna have to go tonight
members the final uh motion on notice
is relating to inconsiderate parking on
footways and grass verges
mrs mason do you wish to speak
thank you mr chairman i just wish to
extend my apologies for the rest of the
meeting i'm afraid i'll have to leave
thank you
council williams council williams please
thank you chairman i'd just like to know
how long the extension is for please
well carry on for as long as we can i'm
going to take the final
motion on notice and take a view after
that councilor williams
thank you
councillor mrs carter thank you chairman
i'd like to apologize that i need to go
i have to get up to go to work in the
morning
thank you
thanks chair i appreciate it won't do
anything to the vote that's just taken
place however
i would draw members attention for the
next um
motion we're going to vote on that
the constitution on 4.12
15.6 amendments to motion part d
reads if an amendment is carried the
motion
as amended takes the place of the
original motion
this becomes the substance the substance
stantive motion to which any further
amendments are moved
i will be seeking clarification
regarding the last vote outside of this
meeting
but like i said i appreciate it won't
change it i just wanted members to be
aware of it
as we go into the discussion for the
next motion
thank you chair thank you councillor
canelo
thank you chairman just to say i should
be leaving the meeting
members the final motion on notice
relates to inconsiderable parking on
footways and grass verges has proposed
so sorry to interrupt um i did have my
hand up
um i'm going to have to leave the
meeting i'm afraid apologies
thank you allow me to continue please
the final motion on notice relating to
inconsiderate parking on footways and
grass verges
has been proposed by councillor mrs
gooding mrs
rowe and councillor steptoe council mrs
gooding would you please summarize and
speak on your motion of notice
members the vehicles parked on grass
verges and footpaths causing an
obstruction for pedestrians
some of these instances have become
a safety issue therefore having sought
advice i would propose a motion to
address this
which if the council were of mine to
agree
could be enforced by use of civil powers
and i would like to explore ways of
addressing these issues
so my motion reads as follows
inconsiderate parking on footways
and grass verges is both anti-social
and potentially dangerous for
pedestrians and motorists alike
furthermore grass verges become
churned up and look unsightly incurring
costs to repair as a result rochford
district council is seeking to
identify with partners including essex
county council highways
and south essex parking partnership set
to explore ways in which traffic
regulations
can be put in place and enforcement
resourced can be made available in order
to lessen the problem
throughout the rochford district
thank you thank you council gooding have
you a
second to that uh emotion
yes i have a
counselor i believe
oh no councillor steptoe apologies
for chairman yes i'm happy to uh second
that
motion um may i speak at this point
you may counsel steptoe thank you
chairman
this is something i feel quite
passionately about
where we live in our particular district
we have areas within our district that
have very narrow footpaths
i speak about my award in particular but
i'm sure this also applies to many other
areas
within our district
here in barling for example we have very
very narrow footpath and in a lot of
cases
they're only on one side of the road
some other footpaths are only just wide
enough
for a single person to walk along at any
one time
yet alone somebody with a with a with a
buggy
i quite regularly go out and of an
evening and i can see
in particular there is a lady
that sadly has in a wheelchair and the
number of times that i have to see
her go out into the road to move around
a parked vehicle into the the main road
through bali
okay there's not a heavy traffic usage
here but that's not the point
the same applies really when you look at
rochford rockford town itself
butchered town is a medieval town
the footpaths there are not the best in
the world they're not particularly wide
and of course the continuation of
footpath parking
just simply damages the footpaths
it makes them that much more difficult
particularly
for people that are blind apparently
dealing with
a lady that lives in rockford who has
terrible trouble
walking along the footpaths in rockford
because of the damage that is caused by
park vehicles
with her guide dog
with regards to parking on grass verges
in some cases this doesn't necessarily
cause an obstruction
but you have to remember chairman the
rochester district council spends some
300 000 pounds a year
on cutting the grass verges
it is made that much more difficult if
they are
churned up and have parked vehicles on
them
when they're due to be cut in some cases
that can mean
that they miss that particular cut and
the vehicle is left
moved and of course it looks terrible
we spend a lot of money as a district
council to actually
make sure that our district looks clean
and tidy
sharing the problem has always stemmed
from the
in the attitude towards
from the police in dealing with
obstruction
it is a low level issue for them and
i'm not knocking them at all they've got
far more important things to do
but it would make sense that the traffic
wardens
that are come from southeast asia's
parking partnership
would have the power where there is not
a traffic
order in place to be able to issue
tickets
currently the legal legislation
throughout the uk
except i believe london does actually
doesn't actually allow this
there has been some discussions
considerable discussions
within the south essex park in
partnership
and with its fellow parking partnership
from the north of the county
to discuss with and how we can get
around this particular issue
it is very important that we do protect
our footpaths we do protect our grass
verges
and stop this inconvenience of when
children have to walk to school and
we're all encouraging them to do that
and for people that are disabled and
people with buggies and what have you
to be able to use the footpaths along
the sides of the road
to their fully extend sorry chairman
i've gone on a little bit there but
as you can see i feel quite passionate
about this particular issue
thank you council steptoe councillor
wilson
thank you chairman i i fully support
this motion um
the one concern that i've got is that i
know that in london it's um
illegal to park on the pavement or the
footway
and i just wondered whether or how i
know that
council stepped up has mentioned it but
um
is there any way of having some sort of
local bylaw that
would prevent this i'd ask that perhaps
for the uh
the legal officer
would you like to come back on that
point actually uh
chairman i can probably come back on
that point has been the liaison now with
us it's southeast asia's parking lot
thank you thank you um the parking
partnership has
uh recently been involved having
concluded a period of consultation
allowing local authorities to adopt the
same powers that are currently held
within
the london boroughs whereas under civil
powers and offense can be created
prohibiting vehicles
from parking on footpaths so
i think that has been addressed i think
that is being addressed by the southeast
ethics parking partnership of how
they're going to
implement it so hopefully that answers
your question councillor wilson
thank you councillor ft thousand mrs
rowe
thank you chairman um i'm happy to bring
this
motion forward too um i have more emails
about inconsiderate parking
than anything else from my residents and
and i totally support everything that's
been said by my colleagues
councillors goodin and steptoe thank you
thank you councillor mrs rowe councillor
ward
yeah thank you very much jim no i i
fully support what's been said
there's no doubt within rayleigh and my
own world of lodge
which have lots of verges that have to
be
uh cut and such like a lot of them have
been churned up by inconsiderate parking
on them
we know we do have narrow roads but you
know
people can get by we also have quite a
lot of disabled people
who are being forced into the road on
their bargains
because they can't get by and
one of the questions i would like to ask
in regards to this with regard to
enforcement
will photographic evidence because
bearing in mind resources are going to
be
difficult to find will photographic
evidence be
acceptable if someone sees a car
parked on the pavement and if that
evidence can be taken into consideration
or had
it got to be an enforcement officer
actually
physically seeing it and giving a ticket
at the time
that would be my question thank you
councillor fd can you answer that
or respond to that thank you chairman um
just just written that down from
counselor ward about photographic
evidence i'm gonna have to explore that
with the
uh with set when on my first meeting be
one of my questions
so hopefully i will keep you informed
when i get some sort of answer
thank you chairman i may be able to help
councillor fd on this particular point
okay yeah kevin south essex parking
partnership we're looking
at um improving their equipment by
having
a camera vehicle i believe they have one
currently working in basildon
and hopefully that will be enabled to be
moved around to various districts
and they were also looking at evidence
where
the wardens as they go around don't
necessarily have to
take photographs of what have you they
can just simply use the registration
number
and take issue a ticket on that basis
can i come back on that please chairman
thank you
clarify my question my question
with regard to that was members of the
public who have a mobile phone
uh the same as they were able to take
various highway issues and photograph
them
you know i would hope you know we are
limited on resources they may have a
mobile vehicle in battlefield that's
going around and such like they can't be
everywhere
but of course residents are everywhere
and most of them have a mobile phone
surely this can be used as evidence
of something that is happening thank you
quickly come back on that
council sorry let's quickly come back on
that mr chief
cameron i did catch that with ian about
the uh
members of the public taking the photos
and i will bring that up at set
thank you councillor ft councillor
wootton
thank you chair um can i say uh i
fully support uh councillor
uh judy gooding for bringing this motion
forward it's a pet hate of mine
and can i fully in the interest of time
associate myself
totally with the comments of counselor
stepdow
i think he summed up exactly my views
perfectly
i agree with him in every single word
that he said thank you very much
thank you council water and councillor
mr shaw
thank you chairman i fully support this
motion
uh one of the problems is the
enforcement resource
um outside the
horse and groom there's um
a verge there which is actually a clear
way
cars are parked on there daily uh the
weekend there was three or four cars
parked
on there there was also cars parked on
the pavement
now they could have actually all been
fined because
as i say it's a clear way but we haven't
got the resources to to do anything
about it
until we get the resources we're not
going to get anywhere
thank you thank you councillor shaw
councillor canel
thank you chair uh two points on this so
first of all
uh an apology um for my demeanor uh over
the last 10 minutes
um taken into consideration counselor
fd's
points around the constitution i do
believe the the vote was proper
and i'm glad i did not abstain however i
do see clarity outside of this meeting
uh for what has gone on in previous
meetings
uh with regards to this with regards
this issue the first point is a
follow-up to council awards
uh outside of the council i have a
full-time job
one of those um building mobile apps
apologies one of the mobile apps we
built was an app called go park
and one of the things we looked to do
here was
uh clarify uh enforcement and
seek to use members of the public to
take photos uh
for the sake of enforcement however the
law currently doesn't
uh allow that um that project
i was involved in maybe 14 months ago
the law may have changed since then
however i'm not aware that it has
i hope that helps members with regards
the
motion uh itself um
i i support the the sentiment behind
this
um i i agree it's it's a pet peeve and i
know for example
in rayleigh um the the tesco express has
had problems with this
which has led to bollards going up um
and i do uh also get resident complaints
on this matter
the um the i note obviously the motion
looks
to work with others which which could
potentially
um curb our influence on on this
so i'm wondering if this is the best way
to deal with what is a
very serious problem and one that we're
all experiencing
uh and see if there are ways we as a
council could explore this for example
do all of the grass verges need to be
grass could we have you know
foot high hedges that uh um
not parkable on for example um which
doesn't need involvement from
from other partners i believe i'm happy
to be corrected on that
uh and also kind of secondary reasoning
behind that
um it goes hand in hand with with some
of the initiatives we've been
discussing this evening without carbon
neutrality
um in some of the london boroughs they
have found that having these type of
hedgerows on roadside actually absorbs
some of the carbon coming from exhaust
pipes
and so i do support the the sentiment
behind this motion i'm i'm just
unclear at the moment if pursuing
enforcement is the best way to deal with
this matter
thank you chair
i'm sorry thank you councillor canal in
particular i thank you
regards your comments in the previous
item councillor mr lucas gill
thank you chairman uh being a a very old
town or village as it was a lot of our
roads are so narrow
um like my road for instance you've got
parking all the way down
visitors come they park on the verge
delivery vehicles come
they park on the verge there's nowhere
else for them to go
it is a bad situation but
if the grass verges were taken away uh
from the paths the road would be wider
and it would help but that is um
a very serious and expensive
project i think thank you chairman
thank you council lucas guild councillor
fd
thank you chairman just to come back on
this um
i'm of in mind we've been the
representative now to the southeast
ethics partner partnership to ask the
question
i sorry to repeat myself a little bit
let's say the department
what i'm thinking about asking them is
the department of transport has recently
concluded a period of consultation
allowing local authorities to adopt
powers that are currently held within
london brothers whereas under civil
powers and it is an offence
an offence can be created for rooted
vehicles from parking on
footpath how is the southeast essex
partnering partnership working with its
partners to create
these civil powers that can be enforced
by sep
relative helping to prevent anti-social
and dangerous behavior of drivers
i'm going to ask that question in the
next meeting
and i will keep members updated on
what's happening with that so hopefully
they might help a little bit
going forward and i really
embrace uh cancer
clinics points with the carbon with the
carbon putting bushes and stuff on
on the verges and maybe that's something
you should take up with the carbon
neutral working party for the future and
i think that's a really good idea
thank you thank you councillor fd
councillor smith
chairman there's a lack of care and
consideration in a lot of aspects of la
of life in our our community
clearly to deal with a situation like
that this
enforcement is is the last step we
should be educating we you
should be using polite words and gentle
reminders
but we have done that now it is
regretfully time for action
and i'm wholeheartedly in in support of
this move thank you
thank you council smith councillor
steptoe
thank you chairman uh yes just to come
back on council canal's point of
uh hedges and uh along the grass verges
you need to bear in mind that the vast
number of our
um green edges are also
um site lines for junctions
and people going on the road the
addition of actually having
small hedges or hedges along those
particular
would fall upon us to maintain those
as i've already said just simply cutting
the grass throughout the whole district
cost this district something in the
region of 300 000 pounds a year
if you've then got to add into that the
cost of actually cutting hedges
two three times a year i think that
would perhaps put it
a little bit out of our reach but i do
take his point that that
uh is perhaps a softer approach of
actually um discouraging people to do
i also will pick up on councillor
smith's point that yes we do need to
educate
um our drivers but sometimes
we need to educate them through a little
bit of a
a stick so they do understand
the parking on grass verges and
particularly pavements
and blocking the pavement is a big
moment
jim thank you councillor steptoes
again thank you chair
um and thank you thank you councillor
certo for
for the follow-up um i may have
misunderstood um
i do take on board the uh the comments
about cost although i think the cost
would be instead of cutting the grass as
the grass would no longer need cutting
if there's a hedge on top of it
um with regards uh councillor smith's
comments i wholeheartedly agree
education
first um i i haven't had the pleasure of
serving as as long as
other members on this call today so i'm
not aware of all of the
education routes we've gone down i'll
take upon myself to educate
myself on those routes but at the moment
i feel like
going through enforcement based on the
the picture i have at the moment may be
over the top
thank you members thank you chair thank
you councillor cannell
i cannot see anybody else indicating to
speak
councillor gooding do you wish to sum up
i would just like to thank all the
counsellors for the support on this
motion
and i take on board the points that
you've made
regarding other options and that is why
i suggested we explore all these other
options
before we take the action that we
propose here if i have your support
and i'd like to move the motion please
thank you councillor gooding
it's already been seconded members
there are no amendments to the motion
so i shall put the original motion to
the vote
as proposed by councillor gooding and
seconded by counsel
mrs rowe um members
i shall call out your name again if you
please indicate whether you like a
recorded vote
um or to voting for against or to
abstain i'm not sure
exactly who is still with us but i shall
read out all the
names on my list counselor mrs belton
no recorded for the motion council mrs
butcher
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor canel
no recorded vote required i thank
councillors
gooding rowan septo for bringing this
forward i do like i say agree with the
sentiment however on this occasion i
vote against
thank you chair councillor mr carter
uh no and for councillor mrs carter i
don't think she's with us
myself uh no recorded vote and four
councillor fd no recording voting i'm
staying on this just because i'm on the
southeast asia park
parking partnership thank you councillor
eves
no recorded vote and four thank you
chair yes it's the gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
councillor hook way no recorded vote and
for
the motion thank you chairman councillor
mr hoy
thank you councillor ionu no and four
councillor lucas gill
no and four councillor mrs lumley
john councillor mrs mason has gone
councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded voting for thank you
councillor merrick
no and four thank you councilman
no and four council newport
news it's gone councillor mrs pavlin
no i'm four thank you councillor mrs
rowe
thank you chairman no and for councillor
mrs shaw
no
councillor smith recorded vote for
council sparing she's gone councilor
stanley
[Music]
no for chairman councillor webb thank
you chairman
no and for councillor
councillor mrs weston no recording
voting for
chairman thank you council wilkinson no
unfortunate
thank you councillor williams
iv thank you chairman councillor wilson
no
and four councilor wooden
thank you members
no recorded vote 26 members before the
uh
afford a motion one abstention one again
so that's carried thank you members
chairman i think there's two abstentions
chairman i think there was two
extensions canelo and
the clarity chair i was against
i'm sorry so i had to apologize if she
was okay
no worries honest mistake i'm aware of
the time but i'd like to
um carry on with item 12 billy chip
scheme um i would like uh council web
please to give us a verbal update
thank you chairman yes happy to do that
so council officers have looked into the
billy chip scheme along with another
proposal that
our partners chess and chelmsford city
council were considering introducing
called the tap and give scheme this
alternative scheme allowed the public to
tap and give through an organization
called greater change
who use all the funds to pay for items
that are needed to break the cycle of
homelessness
both schemes have positives but to date
neither chelmsford or rochester would
have sought to implement either scheme
this will be reviewed in the future but
the main reason for this is that the one
positive outcome of the coronavirus
period
has been the strength of the government
desire to keep rough sleepers
off the street and in accommodation
in rochford district the housing team
picked up 10 rough sleepers
through the emergency coronavirus public
health guidance
i'm pleased to say that all of these
were accommodated and remain
in accommodation although the housing
team were aware of one entrenched rough
sleeper
the others that were supported came
under the new public health emergency
definition of rough sleepers
and were not entrenched off sleepers but
hidden homeless
for example those sleeping on a sofa
that was staying with friends
or family because of this progress the
urgency of developing either the billy
chip scheme
or the tap and give scheme has not been
so pressing
as all the known rust sleepers in our
district are housed
this is not to say that in the future
others may become visible on our streets
and we will then need to consider these
schemes but i do hope that
schemes like this will continue to be
less needed as we succeed in our
commitment
to end all rough sleeping locally thank
you mr chairman
council away a councillor mr carter
yeah apologies chairman but i've got an
early start so i'll have to leave the
meeting
thank you councillor hawkway
thank you chairman uh likewise i'm i'm
gonna have to uh
leave the meeting uh due to the lateness
thank you councillor
members does anybody else wish to speak
on this item
members there are no uh members
indicating they wish to assure
speak um uh is that noted members
and i will confirm that on the
assumption of your agreement
unless anyone clicks on the raised hand
icon
there is no such raised icons
that members has been agreed and noted
thank you
members i quickly go on to item 13
cct working group and again councillor
webb
will introduce this item counseling
members i am pleased to present this
report to you can i particularly thank
andy parkman for collating
the large amount of information and
talking us through it
so well before putting together this
final report
can i also extend my thanks to the
members of the cross
party working group that consisted of
councillor butcher
councillor eaves councillor milne and
councillor wilkinson
for their support and insight over the
last nine months
as we met together many times and looked
at this serious issue i intend to say a
few words before handing over to andy
to take us through the bulk of the
material and then the members of the
working group will cover in more detail
some of the key aspects of our work
during this time as a working group we
have been presented with a vast array of
information
carried out a successful district-wide
consultation
which had over 650 responses and we also
spent a day visiting a cctv
demonstration
showroom the data that andy will take us
through contains some interesting
statistics
however one key highlight that i would
like to draw members attention to
is on page 13.3 section
2.6 here
we see that rochford has the lowest rate
of recorded crime
per 1000 population of any district in
essex
this as i'm sure members will agree is
something that we should be very proud
of
however from the work we did identify
two wards within the district that we
felt would benefit from cctv
these were weekly award primarily in
rayleigh high street
and roach south ford in and around
watchful town centre
it is also felt that a mobile cctv unit
as a resource for the district would be
beneficial
as a working group we have enclosed
estimated costs for this work in the
report
however they are not full costings as we
have not yet looked at the exact
location of the cameras
within each world and this may very well
increase the overall cost
as a working group we agreed that it was
time to update the council on our work
to date
and to advise members of the future work
that is needed
before a fully costed scheme can be
presented to members
however i would reiterate that on
balance
looking at the evidence and taking into
account the results
of the consultation we would be keen to
see
cctv installed in rady high street
rochefort town center as well as a
mobile cctv provision
that can be used across the district
thank you members i will now hand over
to andy parkman to take us through the
four reports
thank you council webb
mr parkman
thank you
mr parker can i interrupt you for a
second we
we can't hear you very well i'm afraid
um you're not coming over at all i don't
know if it's me can anybody else
hear him okay this is
this video council mcpherson can you
repeat that please
would it help if andy turns his video
off
can you hear me
the other members of the working group
have also been asked to
speak on um the update to full council
perhaps we if appropriate they could um
introduce their sections if that's okay
okay counselor
next councilor meal
yeah thank you before councillor milne
comes in could i suggest to andy
that we had this problem in one of our
working groups before he swaps to
other equipment that did work a lot
better uh rather than using the council
equipment
thank you councillor eves
excuse me is this his laurie shaw i'm
going to have to leave the meeting thank
you
council emil would you like to give us
your report uh yeah
um i mean i as i was double hatted at
the beginning of all of this
with raley town council i have been
impressed with
the work of the group and with andy his
research has been meticulous
and completely agree with the findings
and of course
where the risks are are in population
centers which is rockford and
uh and of course rayleigh um
from that point of view i think they're
putting together
um a nice informative case
for the council to consider and from
that point of view i mean personally
i mean i i'm in in favor of it all
and i think i'd like to thank them all
for all the work they've done
and particularly mike wilkinson actually
for getting the ball rolling
um so there's where we're at at the
moment
uh particularly being part of the parish
council the town council
we're we're awaiting obviously the
outcome at rockford
um to then see how we can
if they decide to move forward uh the
practicalities
exactly that so i'd just like to thank
everyone and take the mick web as well
because
he's held it all together and they've
embraced new technology
and they've actually actually done quite
a good job
so i don't want to take anything away
from andy because andy's got all of the
more technical details and just like
thank you
thank you council emil uh mr councillor
eaves would you like to say
comment on this one yes thank you chair
uh it's been quite a privilege to be
part of this and uh so i
welcome the opportunity to be part of
this working group um
i was going to speak about the uh the
site visit that we did to dahu
uk over in maidenhead six of the members
of the group
went over there to view the demo demo
suite that they have over there
who are one of the major um
manufacturers and suppliers of cctv
these days
one of the reasons being why i wanted to
actually have a just a do a quick
presentation on this one
was that i wasn't aware and i'm not sure
if
many of the other members are aware of
the standard of the equipment and what
it can do
now uh what we will have been used to in
the past will be grainy pictures
appearing on
uh crime watching sort of things like
that where the technology has moved on
massively since then we were shown
equipment
that uh nowadays where
in the past you would have had to have
had as a result of an instant
an officer or someone sitting in front
of a cctv monitor
and trawling through hours and hours of
tape
what you can do now the equipment can
actually filter out
to be looking for
let's say for instance someone with a
dress someone with a red top
someone holding an umbrella someone with
a hat someone with a bag all those
things can be filtered in and so
actually finding perpetrators or people
you want of interest
that come up from cctv can actually
be identified very very quickly so one
of the
areas that the we were presented with
which
um andy made very clear um is
that it's in
being able to uh bring prosecutions
uh where the usefulness of the cctv will
be so
i would um strongly recommend
uh as bob has already said that
we do follow through to the next stage
on this uh being mindful of
the quality of cctv that there is these
days
is massively better and that the
resources it can add to safety and
policing of the specific areas that he'd
be allocated to
would be quite significant thank you
chair thank you councillor he's very
helpful
council williams thank you chairman
um i do have consum some concerns and
perhaps i should i should
uh note uh non-pecuniary interest in
this being a
chairman of rochester parish council we
did look at this sometime
and this system does seem to be pro
sorry reactive
um in really it's not too bad if you
have a problem in railing the police
station is up the road where
offices are if there's a problem they
can be there in rochford
it's most of the offices come from canby
by the time they get there the issue is
over
or move somewhere else so i do have
great concerns about whether or not this
would work in the rocha parish
thank you thank you council williams
councillor ionu
so chairman just just point of order
please uh there are two other members of
the working group who are expecting to
speak as well before we go to questions
if that's okay
sorry counselor so wilkinson that's okay
thank you chad okay in that case i shall
go straight to
councillors councillor butcher then the
councillor wilkinson
i won't forget you councillor iona
councillor mrs butcher yeah thank you
chairman
um yes i just want to reiterate what um
what's already been said about the
uh the group the working group we we
visited many places and found out a lot
of information and the thing that
impressed me was the technology that is
available
but i was much more impressed with the
mobile unit as well because with a
mobile unit
it can benefit the whole of the district
because it can be it can move around
wherever it is needed
and there may be a problem in a
particular area and we often have this
that there is
um anti-social behavior in an area and
it gets moved on
well if you've got a mobile unit the
mobile unit can move on as well
and uh you know that was that was very
very impressive
i understand that there's been flight
tippers have
been um dealt with because of of
uh these mobile units but technology is
advancing
rapidly with this and uh i was very very
impressed with it so
we all started with an open mind but i
think
particularly with the residence views
which was
um they came out very much
in support of having cctv
and it's the residents that we're
working for and
i think that we've got to really look at
going for this
thank you thank you councillor butcher
councillor wilkinson
thank you chairman and thank you for the
previous comments uh
i'd like to put on record my thanks to
councillor webb um for the way in which
he's taken this project forward
um and he's the the open
uh cross-party way in which he's done
this and there's been
no party politics in this whatsoever
we're just on the same page open
as counselor butcher says um trying to
do the right thing and it's been an
absolute privilege to to be part of this
group
and it's interesting actually to have
heard counselor williams before i've had
a chance to speak because
i could probably um ask some of his
points because
what's important this is to recognize
that this isn't rochester district
council trying to inflict cctv
on on on anybody and i'm sure that's
what castle williams is trying to
suggest
and we we've looked at this holistically
as a
from the district points of view rather
than uh from parish to parish to see
you know if there is a need if there is
a demand um if there is a justification
of where that may be
um and as uh councillor webb has
already alluded to those two primary
areas are rochford and rayleigh
and and it's very very important to the
working group and that we work
with the parish strike town councils
of those respective areas um and in
actual fact the
the the invitation has already been
extended to to those particular
um councils for one of their members
um to come and join us on the working
group
um so that we can formulate this
together because this is about
us all working together you know to make
sure that the system that's
that's that we get for rayleigh is fit
for rayleigh a system that we get for
rochefort is fit for ruptured
um and and it'd be wrong with us to
exclude our partners within the parish
and town councils for that
um now i'm not going to speak for cancer
web at all for the working group as a
whole but i'm sure
that they would agree with me that you
know if on working with rochester
with ruptured parish council rather
ultimately
it transpires that there isn't a need or
they don't perceive their spare need
then that may be a view that's taken by
the working group that we don't need to
put anything there
um and i'm sure that will assist
financially as well but
um you know it would be wrong of the of
the group to have ignored any part of
the district and that hasn't happened
um and and i'd just like to reiterate my
thanks to councillor webb
chairman for the way which is he's led
this group thank you
thank you councillor wilkinson
counselling councillor ionu
you chairman uh i'd like to bring up a
non-procurement interest of
being chairman of the rochford chamber
of trade
i commend all members
in the working party including council
web for engaging across
the cross parties and bringing this to
uh to a point where we can go to a phase
two
where we can actually implement this in
both the awards
one of the points which i'd like to
raise is with regards to
another group which hasn't been
mentioned is the chamber of truths
both in raleigh and rochford whether
those two
chambers will be involved in the second
phase
in providing business uh
input in whether the they can actually
support the scheme
as well as uh bringing up their concerns
on the cctv whether they do require cctv
uh or not uh so that is one question
which i would like to post to counselor
web but from my perspective as
uh chairman of the cha rochefort chamber
of trade
i can confirm that speaking to
businesses within the
rochford area they're in total support
of the cctv
but would like representation onto
the uh the working party in phase two
and whether that can be confirmed many
thanks
to the web can you respond to those two
questions please yeah thank you for your
crying comments
counsellor i only um absolutely we do
need to get the
chamber of commerce and trade involved
um i understand that you're already
linked in
with the israeli town council and
watchful parish council
so perhaps representation will be best
made
to those bodies um he will be invited to
join the working group
absolutely as councillor wilkinson has
outlined
we very much need to be working with the
parish and town council
to discuss within their findings and to
make sure that if this project does get
taken forward
then it's done in the best way possible
that meets the needs of our residents
so i would ask that if you can speak
to the parish and town council to make
sure that you're linked in with them
and then absolutely we do need to hear
the views of the the businesses
um and what they want as well i hope
that's okay councillor ionu
thank you for watching thank you very
much to councilwood you answer my
questions
councillor wilson
thanks chairman um in the past i worked
at the home office on a number of
um projects to do with cctv and
automatic number plate recognition
systems um
i've got a couple of issues with i'm not
not against this at all
um but what i'd like to know is how does
how would
a rockford district system tie in with
things like the wider home office
initiatives
and police force operations is the first
thing
um and who would be responsible for
tasking where these mobile units go
would that be brought to a district
council would it be the police
and i know what chief inspector miles
says in the report which is good
um but um would
if it was that imperative would not the
police be um
funding this um and finally it
is a point and it's a concern um
that i've seen certainly in holbridge
where there is cctv that's operated by
um the parish council but unfortunately
by the time these incidents have
happened
there's no police there to enforce it
that that would be a concern
yeah thank you councillor wilson and i
think one of the things that we learned
from the
the away day that we had was the
technology that is there
and in some sense it depends on how much
we want to spend on the type of cameras
that we get
for example some would be more than
capable of actually carrying out a
number plate recognition that that's
part of the capability there
but then you're looking at a more
expensive system to do that so that's
part of what
we're thinking in terms of phase two is
actually looking at the spec
of the cameras and what is needed for
each individual area
in terms of the the mobile cctv i think
that would also need to be looked at in
terms of how we would respond to an area
i know from from brief conversations
that there's been discussions uh
some of the parish councils in terms of
supporting um an investment in cctv a
mobile cctv unit
um and then there'll be a conversation
that would be had i'll presume with andy
parkman
liaising with parish councils in terms
of where there was a hot spot area that
would benefit from cctv
um and then that will be a discussion
that will be hard as to when they'll be
able to use the
the equipment if other members of the
working group
have any other views or comments please
please feel free to
to chip in hopefully that does answer
the question though the point of order
chairman
we're coming up to 11 o'clock how long
do you think
the remainder of this report will take
and then
the vote subsequently which i believe is
just for noting
can you give us an idea please thank you
yes thank you council webb um i
have five more members who wish to speak
on this item uh i will allow those five
no
more then i shall take the vote and can
i ask the future speakers to be
succinct and um quicken what they say
please
um bearing in mind the time councilor
macpherson
i will be good chairman i'm gonna have
to leave this meeting now
thank you
i'm also going to have to leave sorry
chairman
likewise chairman i do apologize
sorry it's councillor carol pavlin
be very quick um i i too should say a
non-pecuniary interest as i'm
deputy chairman at rochas parish council
however
i disagree with my um equally wonderful
all
the lovely chairman there um and i do
think this is a good idea
um cameras have moved on um the cameras
that we used to use years ago a waste of
time
these can be good i get what um
councillor wilson is saying that the
police should be paying for them
but let's be honest the police have not
got the funds for this
and it won't be one of their priorities
but looking at the report and i think
it's page 13
something um the
91 of respondents found that the
presence of a public cctv system would
make
their town safer 90.3
respondents found that cctv represented
a good use of public money
so they've they're making the choice
here and i think it's a good idea i like
the idea of mobile units
i can see parishes there then
contributing to them because obviously
if they've
got a problem they could probably try
and have from the units
thank you thank you councillor fd
mr chairman uh on hold i support this
motion but just a word of caution um
facial recognition uh we've already got
we've got five million cameras
around five million cameras installed in
the uk
um we need to keep a good eye on this
make sure
it doesn't start going into a civil
liberty civil
liberties it's getting late and that's
my
two penny for thank you
thank you chair i will try and be brief
uh forgive me
um another good example of uh
collaboration across party um bringing a
good report to
full council and so thank you for
everyone involved um
the points i wish to make are
surrounding 2.2 on
13.1 as as um
i believe them potentially missing the
idea of helping in prosecution so i
would just ask
councillor webb or any members of the
working group
uh if this was considered and and if so
if there are any reasons why it was
dismissed
um and then also to pay our attention to
um section five um
on that starts on 13.12 continues on to
13.13 we would take on um
some responsibilities um and um
if if um
if we don't think this is going to uh
reduce crime as
the report states and we're not sure we
have all of the resources
to aid once crime has been detected um
is the trade-off worth it with regards
to taking on those legal
responsibilities
uh thank you chair councillor webb can
you respond to those
questions yes thank you chairman so
issue prosecutions was was raised and
certainly if cctv
was installed in the district we'll be
looking to make sure that we're working
with police colleagues
that they would have access to the
footage and that they will be able to
use them in a
a court case in terms of
the level of impact on on crime um
i mean we look through a vast amount of
data it is very difficult to discern
exactly the benefits of cctv
some studies would show that there's a
greater benefit than
others but also we're looking at the
needs of the residents and the public
reassurance and and as councillor
mcpherson has outlined
um 650 responses to a consultation is
one of the best that we've had as
a council and if you look at the number
of people that actually want cctv it's
96 97
and they also agree that it's a good use
of public funding so
i think on balance when we we take those
to
um two items and we weigh them i think
we say with
there is an argument that actually it
will reduce crime and actually there's
an argument a very strong argument
that our public will get some strong
reassurance from that as well
um if other members of the working group
want to ship him
please feel free to but i hope that
gives you some reassurance thank you
councilman
councillor williams
thank you thank you chairman um i'm not
sure if
members are aware but we already do have
number plate recognition cameras in
rochard
and they are installed and run by the
police and they've managed to catch
quite a few motorists without tax
insurance
i'm not sure if raley has the same i can
confirm that
up until today rocha parish council have
not received
an invitation to join this um this
working group
um um i i'm not against having
cctv and i you know even if it doesn't
work because the camera would be a
deterrent i suspect but
uh i will support the motion um
and i hope it does make a big difference
but as i said before i do have my doubts
thank you thank you council wilkinson
number council will come will be the
last speaker on this item
council wilkinson thank you chairman
very quickly just to answer a point
raised by councillor wilson
um he makes a very good point and it was
a concern of ours as well
um with regards to he's mentioned about
the cameras in holbridge
um and the lack of police response um
there are obviously
there are two uh potential police
responses
to cctv to instance one is intermediate
um
so something's happening has been viewed
on the camera and the police turn up
and that's becoming less likely as
police resources become thinner
the second of course is which i was
involved in which was after the fact
um and when you're investigating a
serious crime uh cctv is one of the
first books to call
um and you can go back and retrieve
evidence that way so
um that it's it it's it's um it's a
two-pronged attack
um so there are there are many ways of
um of trying to get it so it's not just
an immediate police response i hope that
answers the question thank you
sheriff i may counsel canal i'm i'm
sorry that he was that was the last
speaker
if you have spoken on this item i'm now
going to go to the two recommendations
we have two recommendations set out on
paragraph 7.1 on
m on page 13.13 of the report
one is that the work undertaken by the
cctv working group
they'd be noted two that it is noted
that further work is required to scope
the location
stroke a number stroke specification of
any proposed cameras
and their associated cost is that noted
members
i will assume agreement unless anyone
clicks on the raised
hand icon
that is noted members that concludes the
business of this meeting
i thank you for your patience and
forbearance for the second
meeting running and i close the meeting
at 11
12 p.m thank you thank you chairman
[Music]
wow
you